test123
testing
she
okay i'd like to go ahead with our
sessions today we have
on the docket we have three bills for
exacting today
we have 381
394 and 420 all our senate bills
so with that um
notice for the committee i i'm looking
at uh
excluding the three bills we have today
we have ten additional bills which we
have to exec
prior to unloading them here
in a several weeks time
so
we may
we may have a meeting next week i will
know more about that within the next
hour or so because we have to have it
put into the calendar
if we do have that we would be doing it
unfortunately this room is used
by
hhs right now too
and and
they have wednesdays
mondays are available tuesdays are ours
and we have monday available if we need
it
i think we
may have it on tuesday i'll let you know
more within the next hour
um
i guess that's it i hope people been
following what's going on in the senate
there's a lot going on down there in the
senate in terms of our education bills
track them and follow them please
so the first bill we have today is 381
establishing an office of advocate for
the special education for special
education
does everybody have a copy of the build
okay i'm going to ask represent cordelia
to make a motion
uh thank you mr chairman i would like to
move ought to pass on
senate bill 381
thank you is there a second yes i'll
second
so we have a motion made by
representative cordelia and second by
representing hobson the motion is ought
to pass on 381 establishing an office of
the advocate for special education
representative cordelli to care to speak
on your motion yes thank you
um a few points i'd like to make
first
this bill
came out of said senate education
unanimously in support
it
went on the consent calendar and was
passed out of the senate
and you might take a look at the
sponsors of this bill
really leadership from both sides of the
aisle
in
we've
we've heard
quite a lot of testimony in the past
from from families
of children with special needs
clearly
clearly there is a need
i think just by the fact that we heard
there's um roughly 30 34 complaints
annually to the department of education
um
in itself is a problem i i think that
points out a problem um in terms of um
their concerns about
the process
this
this bill was an outgrowth of uh
study committee last fall
um
really
as a result of the testimony
a number of
people got together and said we need to
do something
we've we've heard
in testimony
that
department of education
there's no evidence that it's not
functioning
i i would disagree with that from
listening to the parents
and
i sent out this
doe survey from last spring which i
think certainly points out the problems
the school explains what options parents
have if they disagree with the decision
of the school
35 percent of parents did not agree with
that
um
it goes on and on
a couple of others i wanted to mention
oh
i was given all the reports and
evaluation evaluations related to my
child prior to the iep meeting
i was given information about the
research that supports the instructional
52 percent said they were not
they're clearly
clearly problems and i think that the
intent of this bill is to address um
those
those areas um
we heard from the
new child advocate and thank you much
for
coming to our committee i'm sure we'll
see you more often in the future
um
and uh discussion about whether it
should be under um
her office um
i think it's important that it be a
separate office i i think the um the
offices it's structured now
is clearly um
given
more
responsibility in the areas of juvenile
justice and dcyf and i think it would be
a
a problem to mix in special uh knee
children with those areas
and i i think that
there was a conference i went to a
couple of years ago and former uh
governor from florida jeb bush
um said
be bold be impatient
and i i took that being patient these
kids are only young once
we have to do something for them look at
the proficiency scores of children with
special needs look at the survey results
we need to we need to act it's on us
right now and for those reasons i ask
you to support the ought to pass motion
thank you very much
is there any further discussion from the
maker of the second
no thank you mr chair i think
representative cordelli covered it quite
well thank you
further discussion representative porter
thank you mr chairman um
i support the idea of the advocate i
think it's great i'm wondering why it is
two things
why it is we would not want to
have
this advocate attached to the child
advocacy office
given that the child
they already might have have contact
with some of these families for
different reasons it seems to be more
unifying and that is also an independent
agency not um overseen by the department
of education or any school district so i
i took to heart what they had to say
and the second ish point that i have or
was wondering
exactly what power
does this
advocate have
to fix a problem for a family i i wasn't
clear during the hearing
what
they would be able to do if a family
came if they worked with a family
and i would like to have that clarified
if someone can do that for me
so anybody would like to respond to
representative porter's question on the
committee
representative cordelli
thank you
um
ideally i would like to see them have a
little bit more teeth but that's not in
the bill that we are presented with um
i i think that
a great part of their responsibility is
information and supporting of parents
with children of uh special needs
but also um identifying where the
problems um exist in the process um and
getting back to the legislature and
others as specified in the bill
you know
something that i think after the office
gets up and operational we can look at
and see
what additional can be done
but i'm sure that they will also be
working
with the department who
might have
uh but i'm not sure how that has
that's a follow-up question
thank you
i guess i'm also curious as to you know
you see when it gets started up
this is a new agency then a new office
that's going to have to start up from
the beginning
how long will it take for it to become
fully functional as opposed to attached
being attached to an
office that is already fully functional
and making this be an additional service
that they provide
i'm just wondering what kind of kind of
time frame you think
it will be
before this independent office set up
under this bill will be
actually effective
representative cornelli
thank you
in either case
hiring of staff with expertise is going
to have to be a a primary
function of the startup
so i don't think that that
plays into one one option or the other
um
but in terms of uh
hiring of staff and so forth uh you know
go through the the governor and the
executive council and uh
um you know i
dare not speculate on how long that
might take
but i'm sure that if this bill
passes and gets signed i i think that
there will be
pressure exerted from special ed
parents
to the governor to uh get the
office up and running as quickly as
possible
rep san luna
and then representative boehm thank you
very much mr chair um
representative cordelli asks us to be
impatient well you know taxpayers across
the state
are impatient
as well and they're waiting for proper
school funding
and
this legislature has done
nothing
to to help move that forward
um
proper school funding would address a
lot of the issues that representative
cordelli talked about because some
districts can afford to provide an
adequate education
on the backs of their property taxpayers
and others can't this legislature has
taken steps hang on i'm getting here
has taken steps with vouchers with
prendapods
and frankly we saw a bill that actually
sought to dumb down the curriculum
and
those clearly
don't do anything
to to address what representative
cordelia is talking about here i happen
to agree completely with representative
porter that that
that an office of a special education
advocate or special education advocate
is a good idea but that it should reside
in the office of the child advocate
and we've we've got we've received
testimony from the prior director of
that office as well as the new director
from from that office
listing all of the reasons why it should
be there
presenting a plan for for doing it tied
in with the next state budget
and furthermore uh how it would would
improve their ability um within the
scope that they that they have right now
their expanded scope that they have
right now which includes education to be
able to meet children's needs in a
variety of different ways
so a special education advocate under
the office of the child advocate would
would would not only be be more
economical from a statewide
basis but
but it would also i think provide a more
comprehensive way of
meeting students needs across the state
so so i support the idea but i oppose
the bill as instruction
further discussion representative
thank you mr chair uh
the office of child advocate now is
mainly dealing with dcys
abusive parents
abusive kids that are abused and whatnot
so i think it's probably better to be a
separate also from what i've heard from
parents
in one case i know of where a parent
in my town
said
my
child isn't being treated right for a
special ed
uh and i called
u.s senator's office and they said talk
to me
it's good parents do not know where to
go
and i think the problem i said well
contact the doe because they have an
office for that now this i would hope
what this does with the office of child
advocate for special ed
they let everybody know that they exist
the special ed organizations and whatnot
so parents know who to call if they are
having problems in their school district
and i think by going to the regular
child advocate office they have enough
on their hands i was on hhs yesterday
they have enough on their hands with
handling
child abuse and those kind of issues and
and uh without being this added to them
adding this to their office is still not
going to take any more
less time than the office getting up to
speed because they have to hire people
just for the special ad and where to go
and whatnot so and it's all under the
same head administrative services so i
don't think it's going to be more or
less
time-consuming for the office getting up
to speed thank you thank you further
thank you mr chair um
so
just for a point of clarification um i
also sat on the house bill 581 study
committee that representative cordelli
uh has referenced and representative
ladd as well um
a couple of things one that
study committee the the
request for a performance audit of
special education services was the
primary recommendation of that study
committee
and my concern is that
we're establishing an office without
knowing what we need
i i i feel like it's a little bit
putting the cart before the horse
in my own mind coming out of that
committee
what i saw the process looking like was
that we were going to order a
performance audit
get the results of that performance
audit and then
take a look at what needed to be done
to me it looks like we're
we're going to spend 500 000 on an
office and we don't know what the task
of that office is going to be
the other thing is that the reference to
the advocate for special education in
the report from that committee
indicates that the advocate will be the
authority in disputes
and i don't see that reflected in the
bill i don't see any sort of
authority if you will given to the
office of the special education advocate
and i'm wondering if that was just an
oversight or uh
whether or not we can anticipate that
there are going to have to be changes to
that
thank you thank you
further further discussion
careful with that daisy chain over there
thank you chairman ladd um
i
as odd as it may seem i do not agree
with my fellow democrats on this
committee
um i do not think this office is useful
uh i think we've done a really poor job
in filling vacancies in the department
of education i think the special
education department is severely over
taxed over there
i listen to representative cordelie talk
about 35 percent of the parents unhappy
that means 65 percent are or are
satisfied statistics only life and make
them lie that way you can turn them any
way you want
the other part is the special education
program already has an operation to go
there to do what they can settle working
with parents
you create this office there is not one
thing in this bill to give them any
authority to change any iep zero parents
not complain about the spread process
they complain about the iep and what the
children get and don't get and i agree
with that the best advocates for any
youngster in the world is the parent and
thank god we have something to do that
all the time that's the best one you can
have for grandparents you need someone
to advocate but when they go in there
and they're frustrated all we're doing
is creating a larger base of more
frustrated parents because this person
cannot do anything to help that iep
cannot i can't get this service i can't
get that service there's nothing in here
that gives this person anything it's a
half a million dollar election year
waste of money i see the bipartisanship
i appreciate that i appreciate the
concept if we fund education as
representative talked about the way it
should be this may not be a big issue if
we have deal how many spaces in doe are
not filled right now haven't been filled
for the last three four years under our
commissioner there's a lot maybe if we
start funding those and filling those we
won't have these issues but this piece
does nothing to help speculate parents
except make them more frustrated in my
belief
thank you chairman thank you further
discussion represent cornell
i agree with what everyone has just said
but i also want to i'm looking at the
fiscal note in the back and it said the
department of education states will be
no impact on their budget however the
new monitoring requirements for schools
could result in an indeterminable impact
on local expenditures so this is another
way of passing the buck down to local
taxpayers and i won't vote for that at
all it's bad enough
thank you representative ellison
uh just to to to follow up uh from what
my friend to my right just said i think
that this is a a waste of money the
money is not well spent
uh jeb bush may have said be bold but
this bill is not a bold bill it is not
it does nothing to help the people that
need to be helped and i speak
from the perspective of things need to
be done and representative cordelli said
we need to do something
well quite often in this committee we
talk about we need to do something and
then the final result that we get is
something that didn't do anything but we
feel good about it because we had a bill
and we've got a name on it and therefore
we took some action on that this is this
is uh this is a false promise
to special ed parents
and that's the way it will be seen
that's what it is
uh and
certainly in its current form uh i'll be
voting against it
thank you uh representative tanner
thank you mr chair i too agree about the
school funding that that's our should
have been our number one focus this year
and wasn't
but uh besides that i think that this um
this position adds another level of
bureaucracy again just to frustrate
parents because it has no teeth
and that
we have we have a system in the
department of education with specialists
in special education we have a complaint
uh part of special education why aren't
we taking some of this money and just
beefing up
what's already in the department of
education um
we heard that yes there were
30 to 40 uh complaints and we were asked
how many resolved about half of them a
little over half of them get resolved
through the department of education
and the other half we really didn't get
an idea
of what happens to those parents uh
whether they
were going on to a different area to to
look for uh results or not but
um special education is a tough thing
it's a tough thing i've sat in iep
meetings and
you know you have people there that
are trying everybody i think is trying
to do the best for the child and
obviously the parent knows the best way
for the child and what the child is like
at home
and the the school is trying to prepare
the child
for a life outside of the school um so
everybody's working towards the same
results
and i know
that i've seen the frustration with
parents and i feel for them
and i think it's um this is not going to
solve anything i think as
representative ellison and and woodcock
said this is just going to be one more
level of frustration for special ed
parents
so i'll be voting against it thank you
representative cardelli
thank you um i just have to follow up on
on funding
um
we've heard um
just the other day
um of a
who worked for 14 months
to try and get services for their child
and finally had to homeschool their
child
i've talked with an advocate who worked
with a family that went bankrupt went
bankrupt trying to get services and yet
we're talking about more funding to
schools i'm talking about services to
kids thank you
i appreciate uh representative
cordelli's position
um i would like to actually ask them
then what services to kids is this
office going to be able to provide just
tell me one
one service that they're going to
actually be able to do
resident districts are responsible for
providing services
so your answer is may i
follow up thank you sir
so your answer is zero
the question there are no services
attached to this bill this bill does
nothing the person has no ability to do
anything
glenn i agree with you the special
parents are frustrated especially
teachers are frustrated school systems
are frustrated but this doesn't help
that and i'm not suggesting we don't
find it better or improve it anything we
can do but there is a process in place
if it's not effective let's improve the
process this isn't it this isn't it
thank you chairman further discussion
yes representative hobson
thank you for taking my question
um i wanted to know if someone could
describe to me the uh petition that was
signed by 700 parents i have not seen
that petition
but it would seem to me that 700 parents
are pretty upset with the way things are
going right now can can someone talk to
that
representative porter
thank you representative
i could send out an email
and ask my 700 contacts to please sign
this petition and i would get 700
signatures
so it depends on where the petition came
from who asked for it who was solicited
to answer it if it went out to the
general public in every school district
and 700 people around the state
answered that petition then i would say
it has a certain amount of weight but we
don't know who sent this petition out we
don't know who it was sent to
and if there are 35 000 or 30 000
special education students within the
state receiving services
it would not be difficult to find 700
people
in one organization that deals only with
disputes with special education so i i
as much as i appreciate petitions
we see them all the time
and i and i question the validity of the
petitions
further discussion on this bill
representative moffatt
thank you mr
this committee
this
year got over a hundred bills
and many of those bills as we like to
put it were not ready for prime time a
lot of them weren't ready for day time
or night time or anytime
so this bill
i see it a little bit differently
i try to as i look at these things that
come to us from the senate is something
that passes the senate i assume is
there's been some due diligence on the
part of the senators i noticed that some
of the it's a bipartisan bill uh senator
rosenwald is a co-sponsor senator
sherman is a co-sponsor
so again my point is as i look at these
things i i think i try to get i try to
give every bill
full consideration but something that
the senate has spent a lot of time on
and has given us i want to honor their
work and and give it um
as much
as much discretion as i can um
and honor their their work as well as
that's that's my point
further discussion representative lekkis
it seems that this advocate
the job is not to make the changes the
job seems to be to do all of the
work at investigating
we've given them authority to look at
the documents from the schools
all kinds of things you know all the
things that the parents would come to
investigate
they can't do anything about it
but the doe can
and so if they then pass off all their
findings to the doe
the doe has the authority to then follow
up
representative mullen
thank you mr chair so um yes
i'm gonna go back to this concept of the
performance audit
right now
we have
in process a performance audit of
special education in the state of new
hampshire
that performance audit is in fact the
investigation of how the system works or
doesn't work in whatever way shape or
form
i'm not sure why we're putting together
a parallel process
when we don't have the results back from
the original performance audit
i'm sure that that performance audit
will reveal areas for improvement
but what if the performance audit comes
back and they say well you know what the
big problem is
the big problem is uh they're completely
understaffed
we've spent five hundred thousand
dollars on the office of the advocate
to deal with a problem that the
performance audit has said is a staffing
issue
there
that there's no benefit to special
education parents to the parallel
process going on what we need to do
is figure out what the problem is the
performance audit
and then address the limitations or the
weak areas that are revealed in the
performance audit and
uh
that's not the authority of the advocate
for special education i look at the
advocates office as like the complaint
department
it's like establishing a complaint
department separate from the department
of education
so i would ask the question you know why
are we undermining the department of
education why are we taking the legs out
from underneath them
before we even know
what they're
doing well and where they need
improvement
that's what the performance audit is for
thank you mr chair i thank you very much
i i think we all must agree that there
is a an issue here that needs resolution
and that uh i sat on that committee with
you representative mullen and
representative cordelli and we heard
some awful things from parents who have
tried and tried and tried to get help in
fact even in this committee we've heard
from a parent who had the lawyer up
and within
four weeks the tutor was provided but
that individual had to lawyer up and of
course it's a real costly battle
we have kids in schools that are going
to be nine year olds nine years old once
in their life
we can't wait
as i see it right now for the
lba to come through with this
performance audit yes we need to have it
i welcome
and i would love to see those results
we're still in the top portion of that
trying to identify the scope of the
performance audit
so we could be looking at another year
year and a half two years before that is
absolutely done
so that's kind of a slow way to get down
around the corner
so i'm of the opinion that we need to
move on this and get something going
and i for one don't see the other
advocacy group doing this seeing that
they don't aren't prepared they
themselves in a letter to us
stated
we also lack
the level of expertise that senate bill
381 represents in a new agency
so they have to gear up as well as well
as you know we'd have to gear up in
d.o.e to
support this endeavor
so i'm all for we i i don't want to kick
the can down the road any further and in
response to some of the things which we
have done here in terms of supporting
children in a state i think we're highly
in order and out saying we're not doing
anything we have done an awful lot
in terms of looking at adequacy and
looking at career technical education
and all the other avenues this year and
made some significant gains which i'm
very proud that we've made
so um
i for one will support going forward
with this yes i believe that there are
issues even within this bill that we
need to work on
but that's another day we have this in
front of us now
and it's come to us with a a buy
parson support out of the senate
came out unanimously out of the senate
it comes out with
senators on both sides that are keenly
interested in education so
um we can talk this one into to death
here but uh
in the long run we need to act and we
cannot kick this can down the road a
little bit further we have parents out
there shouting for help
thank you
representative boom
thank you mr chairman i'd just like to
make a comment
this looking at the responsibilities
that this job has
it could be a step to preventing
or stopping the parent from having to
get a lawyer to sue
and and the results of
what the advocate does
may help
the parent sue
so it's a good position because they're
not they're outside the doe
they're monitoring all the stuff that
you're advocating for the parent
for the child on what's needed they're
collecting all this information so
it could help
the parent from not having to get a
lawyer thank you thank you
represent luna
thank you mr chair so um
parents are shouting for help there's a
lot of people around the state that are
shouting for help taxpayers are shouting
for help
as well and um and
we've talked about it a lot
um uh and a little bit on this bill but
properly funding our schools is going to
go a long way to uh to helping to
address this problem i think we've all
been to uh to a lot of school board
meetings and a lot of school district
meetings and a lot of budget committee
meetings where um where a lot of people
come in and express concern
about special education costs
and so it's no wonder why there's
districts all across the state that are
very in tune with with controlling their
special education costs whether that
means hiring an attorney
for the district and uh and taking a a
an adversarial position when it or or or
a very careful position when uh when
when looking at a a student's potential
special education needs
and and so that clearly puts parents in
a position where they're going to be
frustrated but if we could properly fund
our schools and schools could could
rather than
rely on on attorneys to control um
their their special education costs but
instead make the right decisions uh
based on a student's needs then i think
we're doing the right things for the
students we're doing the right things
for the parents and doing something like
this and and i think it's very clear
that 381 doesn't have any teeth uh in
fact we don't even know where to put the
teeth because we haven't had a
performance audit but but 381 isn't
going to put
the um the special education advocate in
a position where they're going to be
able to change
um a a school district's determination
and if we put if we can put this money
um as well as the money that's uh that's
being appropriated or that could be
appropriated hopefully through house
bill um
420 towards uh towards supporting
um and funding
school districts taking a little bit of
relief off the local taxpayers who who
vote for their school boards and hire
their superintendents then i think we're
doing the right thing for uh for
students and families across the state
so that's the way to do it thank you
further
excuse me
the thing that really struck me about
our hearing was the fact that
34 students come to the doe for 34
parents 34 cases we have a place in the
doe that deals with all this stuff
and it doesn't get used and so i have to
ask why why if we have all these
disgruntled parents do they not go to
the doe
and that's a big question
and um i don't know whether it's they're
intimidated by the idea of the doe and
they don't want to go there
i can see that as an issue if this was
in that other agency where
parents who are dealing with kids with
learning disabilities
may be saying
why are they sending me to the to an
organization that deals with juvenile
delinquents there's nothing wrong with
my kid
they don't misbehave or anything they
just need the special ed help and so i
can see that being a reason
why we wouldn't put it in the other
organization
i wonder and i don't know the answer
but i wonder if they had somebody who
was not with the doe
who had the title of advocate if they
might feel more comfortable bringing
their kids there than going before the
doe i don't know i was quite disturbed
by the fact that there was only 34
going there and i know i did talk to a
parent from my town the other day
and i said well why didn't you go to the
doe and she's like well i think i have
to be ready to
to
um have a lawsuit or something to go
before the doe and it's like no
i you know i don't know and i don't know
if just having that friendly title of
of um
advocate would make parents feel more
comfortable i don't know what the answer
to that is but i do ask that question
thank you
further just represent tanner and then
representative porter thank you and and
thank you representative lakers because
that's my question also
is why are we not doing something with
the department of education instead of
creating a whole new bureaucracy under
this office of of um
advocacy
they have lawyers now at the doe uh
certainly with additional funds they
could hire
another lawyer just specifically for
special education they have a complaint
department maybe that isn't advertised
as well maybe that's something the
performance audit would show
it certainly would be more efficient
to do it under the department of
education instead of a separate advocacy
group and that's why
you know i can't support this bill right
now i think if we had a study committee
we're not kicking the can down
the wrong road
we're trying to make sure that it's the
right road and i think sometimes
jumping on something like this being
impulsive about it has unintended
consequences
and also a financial burden so
thank you for bringing that up
thank you uh representative nelson
thank you mr chairman as a special ed
teacher and a special ed administrator
for 25 30 years
i would be more
concerned if all of a sudden somebody
walked in as the independent officer
special ed
i'm just telling from my spot i would be
a little nervous so i think this is
really a good idea to go with
thank you representative porter
thank you mr chair um i saw recently an
annotated version of this bill that came
from i believe miss dunham who works for
pic
and her concern was
the use of the term advocate and how
that
would be interpreted by families
as someone who would be able to be
present
um
for them
at hearings and things like that and
that she she suggested a different
term be used
you know we all want to help these
parents and i'm just concerned that this
is going to set up a system that sounds
like it's going to help
you and
ends up
having no teeth and
really not helping much with your
particular child it's
it
it just worries me that's all i would
like to see us do something that
actually would work and perhaps getting
the department of education's
special ed
complaint department advertised and up
to speed so people understand what's
going on with it
would be more helpful and representative
nelson you might be right saying an
independent person is coming in to
investigate
might have more teeth for the special ed
department i don't know about that
it would sound more like they have no
authority to me but that might be just
my interpretation so it's not that we
don't want help for these parents that
have got concerns
but we want to do it in a way that's
actually going to help them and i'm not
thank you
further discussion on this bill
not seeing any uh madam clerk would you
please call the rule
for me
no
madam clerk
thank you
we're voting on senate bill 381 dash fn
a this is establishing an office of the
advocate for special education
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm
representative lacus
no representative moffett
yes
representative hopson
representative ford
yes
representative soti
representative nelson yes
representative luno
no
representative cornell
tanner
no
representative ellison
represent mullin
no
representative woodcock absolutely not
representative porter
no
representative hall no
and representative sullivan
chairman ladd yes
so
the motion fails ten excuse me
can i make a motion i'm gonna call a
caucus at this time
uh wait can we review that can we review
that that
vote i believe it was ten no nine yes
yes that's i i said it backwards i have
it correct i'm sorry about that so we're
gonna have a caucus at this point in
time the result of the vote please
chairman
she just announced it so ten
the vote nine to ten the vote field yeah
thank you
so mr chair could i make a motion of
interim study
no we're gonna have a caucus at this
point in time for about 10 minutes
then uh we'll come back and make motions
thank you
yeah you should probably say
you know the nine first
for everybody have because we're
convene uh this uh
session right here the executive session
and i'm going to ask representative
leicas for a motion
i move reconsideration
represented
second
thank you
so we have a motion on the table to
reconsider our last action and it's been
made by representative uh lekkas and
and
this go ahead represent luna thank you
very much mr chair i was wondering given
the um
given the the discussion deliberation we
had this morning where i think a number
of very strong points and there were a
number of questions brought up if we
might be able to recall uh director
sanchez to uh to talk a little bit about
we do have a motion for reconsideration
on the table so we need to before we're
going to have any further discussion
we're going to have an action on the on
the reconsideration okay
yes uh a point of uh question
um does the second also have to be on
the prevailing side for reconsideration
no
no in in the committee hearings you can
actually you don't have to be on the
prevailing side one way or you can offer
ask for reconsideration on a vote for a
number of reasons so there's emergency
purposes and all that i've been through
this before
and
okay madam clerk would you call the role
rather than a chair
yes would this motion be appropriately
uh discussed as other motion in terms of
the person that made the motion the
second if they want to speak to it
i i will allow the person that made the
motion and
to speak to it if
if she would like thank you
yes i just wanted to say
i mean
thinking back of
the conversations i have had with
parents
first off
i do not believe that parents would want
to go
to an organization that is known for
dealing with delinquent children when
they just have a kid who's not getting
their
dyslexia
you know taken care of or whatever i
think that's the wrong organization
and
the fact that only 34 people are coming
to the doe which has the ability to do
these things
why is that and i just think i
i've come to the conclusion that parents
would be much more likely to use an
advocate for special education
and so let's give them the opportunity
and then we can think about next year
putting in more teeth or giving them
more ability as we see how that goes or
taking or getting rid of it if it
doesn't work if if parents are still not
going to it we can get rid of it but
at least to start with let's give it a
chance
okay we'll remove this
yes um you know
thank you very much given representative
likus's um rationale for uh for moving
um uh reconsideration
um based on the limitation of the office
of the child advocate for just to
work with um i think the term the term
that was used was was delinquent
children believe their role is much more
expansive than that extensive than that
and i think i think it would it would um
be helpful to this committee to hear
from director sanchez you know in terms
of
in terms of addressing what they're what
they're what they're
i'm not going there with that right now
we're in the middle of reconsideration
we're going to have
we're going to call the role right now
and and uh madam clerk would you move
forward yes this is reconsideration of
senate bill 381 relative to the
definition of a child with a disability
under special education laws
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm
representative lacus yes represent
moffett yes representative hobson yes
representative ford yes representative
saudi yes
president nelson yes
representative luno
representative cornell no representative
tanner
no representative ellison no
representative mullin no
representative woodcock
from porter no
representative hall no
representative sullivan no
chairman ladd
yes
so
ten to nine reconsideration
okay the bill's back on the table
represent cordelie
we have a motion for out to pass made by
represent cordeli and second by uh
representative boehm
so represent cordelia do anything
further to
state on your motion
uh
just um
teeth
previously
um and uh i would just say that uh
the
federal law uh comes into play with that
and that's something we could look into
in the future as to
uh how much um teeth could be given to
an office
of this kind
but that certainly can be looked into
any further discussion representative
luna thank you very much mr chair i
believe the characterization of the
office of child advocate
does not properly reflect their their
actual role
in the state of new hampshire
and what they've done
since the the office was created
[Music]
over the last um i think it was six
years ago
and um five or six years ago and uh and
and where their role is going with uh
with to to be able to provide
comprehensive advocacy for uh for
children across the state and um and i
certainly don't believe that that i have
sufficient familiarity with the office
of child advocate to speak to it and
would really appreciate if if we could
recall
um cassandra sanchez to um to to um to
again enlighten the committee as to as
to their current role their expanded
role the direction they're going with um
with advocacy and education thank you
further discussion
so
there was there was a question that to
the chair and that if we could recall uh
director sanchez
yeah um
director uh cassandra sanchez has uh
previously provided us a memo a letter
from her agency
and she has spoken with the committee
prior to
i don't think there's any
uh characterization of the the agency in
terms of
whether they're doing your job one way
or the other i i think we all believe
the the
the child advocate is
doing a
a job in accordance with what they're
required to do by statute
my reference earlier was certainly just
that i had read a specific sentence out
of the letter from
uh director sanchez which stated we also
lack the level of expertise that senate
bill 381 represents in a new agency
that's what i spoke to now i don't think
anybody's trying to say that um the
agency's uh
not performing or what i don't think we
have that expertise to make any kind of
a statement like that seeing we're not
involved with it
director sanchez is welcome to come up i
don't want another presentation if
there's a specific question for her then
that question can be asked we've done
that before i would love to ask a
question to director sanchez if
director sanchez is willing to come
forward
thank you very much mr chair thank you
very much um um uh director sanchez for
for again taking the time with this
committee this morning i was wondering
if you could um uh tell us a little bit
about
the expanded role into education and and
what what your office's plans are to be
able to uh to fulfill that role and
provide
comprehensive services as a as a child
as an office of child advocate
yes so this is newer expansion um this
took place in december 2020 so it's a
little bit over a year now that we have
our expanded jurisdiction for oversight
of all children within the state of new
hampshire so that would include special
education that is not specific to
children with delinquency issues that is
not specific to children involved with
dcyf that is all children across the
state of new hampshire
in that we also understand that there's
a lot of educating for our office to do
a lot do not know what we do right now
and they do not know what we are trying
to do so one of the big main steps that
we are looking to take
is to schedule meetings with
superintendents across the state to
educate them about our
new le our new ability to help all areas
of a child the the to educate them on
the facts that we do have access to
child records if needed to educate them
on the work that we do with families to
help support them in the process whether
it be special education whether it be
general education we work with all
children across new hampshire and
there's a lot of educating to be done
across the state about our new
jurisdiction
thank you thank you
representative
representative uh lekkas do you have a
question
i had a comment and i guess i should
also say it to you
i was not in any way knocking your
organization nor was i saying that was
my opinion of your organization i was
saying that that was a common opinion
amongst parents and we're looking at how
do we attract parents and that was all
that was so i just wanted you to know
that was no knock on your organization
at all
thank you and i do believe that we
understand that as an organization we
understand that we need to reach the
parents we need them to understand what
it is that we do so that is another
initiative that we are taking on is to
make sure that we are educating the
public educating parents meeting working
with the parent information centers
part of educating the superintendents
are for them to guide families to our
office when they are struggling and
having issues but again we understand
there's a lot of educating to do and
that is where our focus is right now
sorry
not trying to micromanage you mr chair
uh thank you for taking my question
uh one of the things that i'm thinking
about um is mission creep um between
maybe an advocate versus um some of your
other agencies
um do you how can you assure that uh
child and family privacy
will not
leak into other areas that you control
so we we have very strong
confidentiality
laws that we follow within our office
and we've been able to advocate for
children in other settings including
within the dcyf system and in
residential settings without
the breach of confidentiality we work
very closely with our statute and we do
feel that we have the ability to
maintain confidentiality
i might add if you were to look at
statute
dash b colon 2 office of the child
advocate established you will see that
they have responsibility
to
make sure that the right the right to
adequate and appropriate health care and
education in accordance with state and
federal law
so the agency has to act in accordance
with all laws of the state and
the feds too and that's uh
within their responsibility
yes represent woodcock
thank you mr chair uh since this is not
the past motion on the floor i'd like to
speak to that
as a review page two of the bill
are you are you going to be
addressing no i'm sorry i i apologize
i'm sorry but make sure that we got our
technical support
i didn't say welcome yesterday but
welcome today thank you
are there any further questions
of the director
thank you very much thank you all go
ahead representative woodcock thank you
chairman
i apologize to that young lady my i
didn't know if you're still on the floor
um so the bill on the floor right now
for discussion um after
some of the disgruntled people weren't
happy uh that there's
that i'm looking at the bill and it says
discretion to ensure all documents
inquire investigate review all documents
discretion to review all documents track
metrics and types agreements measure
track implement documents cut make sure
all copies are relevant documents create
a new form document and you get all done
so what to do he prepares a report for
the governor there is still nothing here
to service the students the parents um
no matter if they're grunt or the
disgruntled there's nothing in here that
says that that they can help service
he's just creating forms and hearing
information and the part that's most
defensive and most uh uh
unenforceable is when we look at section
c on page two and i'd like you all to go
to that and i'm sure you all have the
bills in front of you because you've
been studying this very hard
uh you don't have that representative
loan i have a copy if you have one you
need it you got it okay okay uh anyhow
it says and the goals and objectives of
being met and the appropriate how is
this person going to take an iep and
determine if the goals and objectives
are being met they have annual
evaluation of goals and objectives they
meet with parents with golden objectives
they have three evaluation of the gold
objective this person can't do anything
i'm done representative thank you thank
you
any any further uh
discussion
madam clerk would you please call the
roll
this is auto-pass senate bill 381 fna
establishing an office of the advocate
for special education representative
cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm
representative blakis yes rosa moffitt
yes
represent hobson
ford
yes
representative saudi yes representative
nelson
representative luno no
representative cornell no
representative tanner no representative
ellison no representative mullen no
represent woodcock
was that porter no representative hall
no
representative sullivan no
and chairman ladd yes
i would just like to comment and you
wonder why people don't have any faith
okay we'll have no more comments like
that please let's stay i think it is
necessary absolutely
concord's turning into washington
okay what i'm gonna do right now
because this is not a it's an executive
session
either i'm going to close this thing
down and pick it up at one o'clock after
lunch or we can do one more bill now
but i want everybody staying focused on
task please so we can move forward and
discuss the bills in front of us
and then keep the comments after we've
so anybody has to take a short break
um is anybody else let's take a uh five
minute ten minute uh recess here for
those that have to walk down the hallway
maybe you've had enough of this
okay folks we're we need to get moving
here
okay uh
i have to be out of here myself by about
five or twelve i have to have the
calendar done by 12 for next week
and so i've got to talk with lindsay on
that so
um
we have 394 coming up and this is the
bill dealing with you know um
age 21 22 etc etc
um
so if we can move this quickly as bill i
don't know we've talked about it many
times prior to
um
uh i have an amendment to the bill
mr chair
okay
let me do a little discussion here first
on this one
we we've been working with the
senate because they've dealing with 15
13.
and you you're we're you're aware of
that
um 1513 is a bill that's dealing with
exactly the same topic
and now we have the senate bill right
here in front of us and there's also a
court case down to rhode island
which is dealt with this and issued a
resolution
in talking with our attorneys over at
the department of education we have two
over there we have chris bond and diana
fenton
one's a colonel one's a light colonel
you know who the colonel is
um
the it's
time and job um
we we have been informed that the
language which initially submitted to us
in 1513
is most likely
going to move forward without a lot of
controversy it
when we've been trying to work with 21
through the end of the semester or
through their
years as being 21 same thing with 22
we come up in conflict with the rhode
island resolution
so we've been advised that the best way
to go with is the
the bill as we wrote and asked we
knocked out of this committee earlier
this year of 1513.
so so let's just have some discussion on
that before we go anywhere with it
ref sermon i thank you um we amended
1513 to the end of the school year in
which the student turned 21 before we
passed it out of committee yeah they're
they're talking about as the bill was
introduced ah the original original bill
before we messed with it
i'm saying that's the one that's going
to be
less controversial right my follow-up to
that um
representative vlad is that i have uh an
amendment to 394 should we get to that
process okay representative cornell and
then representative woodcock you had
your hands up i i don't know if you can
but can you just briefly
the difference between the bill we sent
over and this one so
that will
not cause it to be a law problem yeah
representative uh uh
cordelia you were the one that
introduced that bill initially as it
came to us why don't you explain
several of us could do it but i think
representative cordelli could do it more
succinctly than myself
thank you uh yes the uh 1513 as
introduced
said
child with disability means any person
between the ages of 3 and 21 inclusive
which
paralleled
the federal
statute
so we do have an amendment that
took
that
original 1513 language and
that's the amendment to 394.
um and we went over that with uh both um
as representative uh lad mentioned with
attorney bond and attorney fenton
yeah so
follow up
so 1513 is is 21 inclusive and doesn't
get into the 22 at all okay
as
as it was introduced to our committee
not as it left our committee
representative woodcock
thank you chairman
um
i didn't bring that file with me so i
don't have my notes on it but my
question is to you as
representative of the committee
have you been in contact with the
people from the senate who seem to uh
have had that bill if they are if they
are going to move it forward as our
initial or are they going to change it i
don't i don't mind glenn
taking your opinion i can't advertise
what i think they might be doing but i
have talked with senator khan
and i talked with jay just yesterday
numerous times
um he did have a amendment which i went
down and and tried to speak with him
yesterday afternoon late
and his administrative assistant was
there he wasn't there his amendment
would establish a commission to look at
this
and the commission would have a litany
of of responsibilities that that
commission would have i indicated to the
administrative assistant in his office
yesterday afternoon late
that
we've been advised by the department of
education attorneys that the way to go
is with the as it came to us originally
i have not had any feedback back from
jay since then is my fault yes thank you
sir is it possible to get um i know you
have to break shortly is it possible to
get a copy of the original bill
and then vote on after lunch so we have
a chance to reread it i i think that
that's a good idea that maybe what we
ought to do right now is
because i'm from i have a copy of that
the one you have representative mullen
um
and
the the or the i have represented khan's
suggestions it's not in no i don't mean
that rick i mean if we're going to go
back to the house bill yeah and we're
going to we're going to negate
i think we're going to negate taking
action on this
then can is it possible if we can get
original copy of that bill that would
actually
yes and what you can also
you can have this amendment right here
which is that bill okay um
you can do both
rick i think it would be helpful to sort
of lay out what what you what
it sounds like your plan is to offer an
amendment to to 394 that has 394 read
exactly the same way as house bill 1513
as introduced
exactly
but but also that rick do you want to
talk about what that kicks off as far as
the the scenic road through the
legislature
well you see if we
if we we revert back to this
then that's going to definitely
go over to the um
it's going to go to the senate as and
we're going to end up in the committee
conference it first goes to finance
yes that's why it's an early bill and
and uh looking at this particular bill i
don't see much of an issue there either
uh it's it's it's going to end up
the end of the road is going to be a
committee a conference and we're just
going to have to
to meet and decide which way we're going
and i would assume
that we're going to try to avoid the
route of all the litigation
representative
so uh with regards thank you mr chair
for taking my question um with regards
to the commit the the amendment that
seeks to establish the commission
is that doa or are we looking to
act on two amendments to 394 today
that would be a discussion for us
um you can always add an amendment to
you know you can
right it doesn't replace it's a separate
it's a new section
yeah so if you if that amendment were to
i i
my gut feeling i i'll tell you what my
gut says right now you we've mentioned
before and you can talk to people over
office legislative services or folks
upstairs in the fourth floor the word's
been put out that a commission isn't
going to go very far this year
in terms of passage
although we've seen several committees
come over from the senate side proposals
so
um
my bet my money would be on that it's
it's it could be added in but it would
probably be taken out somewhere along
the way
it's okay i'm just looking to execute my
responsibilities
if you if you like what we could do is
just not take any action on this one
right now come back after lunch you
could have a chance to talk with some
folks you could talk to with
senator khan et cetera
and and and uh
check with this office and see if
they're good with the way 1513 initially
came
i think that's probably the route we
should take
take action after lunch on this bill and
discuss it then
yeah yeah
okay
i know you need to break now where do
you where do you want us to come back at
one o'clock you can go home take care of
yeah yeah
okay any
anything else so we'll break and come
back at one o'clock
okay i think we're ready to go ahead uh
i'll convey to represent luna what we
all agreed upon that anybody arrives
late buys lunch
for the committee at the
okay um so we're going to open up and
continue with the executive session for
394 which we were discussing
prior to lunch
and so i'm going to uh look to represent
thank you mr chairman um i would like to
move ought to pass and uh offer an
amendment
you serve a second
on the motion representative like us
hi second thank you
okay now you can offer your
your amendment
thank you um the amendment which i hope
you all have is uh
do
you want me to go into it well is
it's the same as 1513.
mr chair while we
shuffling are we going to be meeting
next tuesday
yes we are thank you starting at 10
o'clock
we will have five bills
and then five on the following
yeah
okay once you go ahead please and
discuss your amendment uh thank you um
this amendment was
drafted
after conversations
with the attorneys from the department
of education
and in particular
attorney bond who was here and testified
about the
rhode island case and its implications
for us
i think there was a similar
so
what we did was uh
go back
to the original uh hb 1513s submitted
which included the language
that
uh child with disability means any
person between the ages of 3 and 21
inclusive
which mirrors the federal
language
in
so we should be on
safe ground legally if anyone wants to
bring a challenge
we we also
would be now in compliance with the
federal
recommendation that we provide services
to children with disabilities through
further discussion from the
second
basically unfortunately we've got to do
this i like leaving it to the towns to
decide but
looks like we're going to be facing
lawsuits if we don't
representative porter
so just to be clear the issue that we
had been concerned about was
young people being dropped from programs
mid-year and this
it doesn't solve that problem
but it makes us in compliance is that
is that where where we are that we
understand that
takes us closer to compliance i don't
want to say that we're all the way there
but we've gotten that from
both of the attorneys at the department
of education i'd like to also take this
moment though to we have another
amendment in front of us while we're in
discussion mode here
and and um
there there's some rationale for that
amendment as well
and
representative mullen would you like to
explain that at all or sure
yeah i would be happy to uh for your
viewing pleasure i have uh
amendment
1488h
to senate bill 394
and this amendment establishes a special
education eligibility commission
the membership of the commission is
outlined on the first page
and i don't think that you'll be
surprised by the personnel that's
included
the house the senate the department of
education
school boards association special ed
administrator
school administrators association and on
uh the
thing the purpose of this
study is to look if we can
at the implications of changing the
eligibility ages to 21 inclusive
so
uh there of course is the definition
itself and and
who that opens up services to that
currently are not eligible for services
uh on page two
we look at defining the end of the
school year that was one of the
questions that came out of our hearing
different districts looking at the
school year is ending at different times
we're looking at the additional costs of
extending
programs both
for residential students and for
students who are non-residential but may
in fact still be in high school
after the age of 18 and uh prior to
either 21 inclusive or getting a high
school diploma
the fiscal impact on differentiated aid
payments the
impact on
developmentally delayed adults some of
whom receive special education services
others who don't there we need to look
at the interface between dhhs and
special education for
those students as well
it's a standard you know legislative
members will receive mileage uh and then
the procedural things uh round out the
amendment
uh
you know much like the performance audit
that we were talking about this morning
uh
changing the definition to 21 inclusive
prior to the study looks like it's the
only option because we need to change
the
age to be in compliance with federal law
but in the meantime that does not remove
from the equation the fact that we need
answers to that
boatload of questions that we generated
amongst ourselves and through listening
to
various stakeholders uh when we heard
this bill last week
i'm happy to take any questions that
anybody might have
okay for all those out there this this
commission and i've had
some discussions with
the original maker of the
of the commission
and uh there there are issues
new hampshire for a long time has been
pretty insulated from what's going on
here with this issue of 21 22 21
inclusive
and
adult education is part of the equation
here
uh you could have a student that's
non-special ed
that's
age 21 and wants to finish finish out
their
high school
graduation diploma
and
that can be now done through adult
education
but that's done through tuition money
but provided by the student
because they're done the 21 bit they're
there they hit that red light you're out
um
so it opens up the door possibly for a
a suit
you're providing it for this student but
you're not providing for this student
i'm not special ed so i don't get the
same type of privilege that type of
thing
and so i think that's that's
somewhat trying to be addressed through
a commissioned study
the commission study also has some
wide-ranging
uh conditions which we're chasing in
special education which has nothing to
do with age 21.
it deals with catastrophic aid if you
read it carefully
and
the
issue that
as an administrator in another state we
had what we call forward funding we knew
what our funding was going to be and we
received that money in the year that our
expenses existed
our our costing our revenue comes in
based upon what we had last year so the
catastrophic aid kid hits you and you
don't have any revenue especially as a
small district you have no wherewithal
you don't have a till you can go knock
on take that money out
and and of course we've tried to address
that through you know working together
as districts i don't think anybody's
taking advantage of that yet but that's
item d i h excuse me on where it says
determining how state special education
cost sharing under the rsa on special
education state aid can be accelerated
into the school year
in which expenses are incurred
so you're trying to get the monies for
that cat aid
child
and so this is a far-reaching study
commission that's what i'm trying to say
it goes well beyond the issue of 21.
and and of course my response to the the
maker of the com of this saying there's
a little bit of non-germaneus in this
um however i know where it's going and i
know that the the intent and the intent
is good intent
so
um
i i the
this commission report is also available
to 15
13 as well
and also available if it ever got
our bill if it makes it out to the house
and out to finance
um
so that that's just my take on it right
now
yes represent woodcock here's the
clarification because i want to be sure
on two things one two on not the
amendment without the prior amendment
revenue quarterly amendment does not
dress it does not address the
end-of-year piece that's correct okay um
well just this is the other part if you
will explain your your writing of this
on line two
and line fourteen where it's bolded
when it says and perhaps representative
moffett who's our writer over there uh 3
and 21 comma inclusive comma but yet on
line 14 it just says and 21 inclusive
when the inclusive is bracketed between
the two commas
does that change the meaning
versus
after
sat directed to anybody well i was
asking or
directed to a professor representative
moffett is the writer so so he may have
it
so
no just where it's bracketed uh
mike does it change the meaning of three
to twenty one verse where it's not
to change the meaning it's all
i read to change the meaning but my
associate to the left told me i was
anybody else want to comment
represent cordelia
thank you in the federal stat statute it
says a free appropriate public education
is available to all children with
disabilities residing in the state
between the ages of 3 and 21 comma
inclusive comma
including children with disabilities et
cetera
so so it is in federal statute it is
bracketed with commas as well so on 14
should there also be a additional comma
excuse me
i think
mr chair
you know likely legislative intent would
would apply okay on that if it were to
be interpreted differently um
but um mr chair i do have a i do have a
comment though on both the um the mullet
amendment and the cordelia amendment if
i might
all right yeah yeah um so i i agree with
you that i think the um the mullen
amendment is um is very important i um i
don't think it um it
comes close to the
uh question of whether it's germaine or
non-germane because i think it uh it is
squarely
you know rooted on on definition of a
child
regarding definition of a child with a
disability under special education laws
which is the title of the bill
and um
and and the study section i think is is
also um
uh very important
in uh in considering um a child with a
disability
and uh in new hampshire's um you know
um
trove of special education
laws which are not the same as rhode
island's laws so um so i think it's it's
somewhat of a leap at this stage for for
anybody to
to say that the
the the court decision in rhode island
um uh is is exactly the same situation
as it would be here in new hampshire
because i think it is it is different it
may be the same or it may it may apply
to us but it might not apply and i think
that's a very serious question and i
think a serious question that this that
the study commission would um uh would
look at so you know it may be true that
new hampshire is not in compliance with
with federal law but it might not be
true it may it may be that we're
fully compliant with with federal law um
i'm i'm
i feel personally that we've been a
little bit rushed
um uh with um uh with this and and even
um attorney bond
suggested that
that that new hampshire may i think you
use the word may be different from rhode
island and that a decision in a um in a
new in a
in a
in a new hampshire case might might turn
out to be different um
all the more reason why i think we do
need to proceed with the uh with the
with the study
um uh at the same time i'm i'm not
you know
totally against you know going forward
with the cordelia amendment either but
but in the um in the
you know sort of the the um
you know under the i guess heading of if
we're going into uh to a statute do we
want to consider some um some cleanup
i'm i'm a little concerned
about um lines 13 through 17 in in
cordelli
um where it could be it could be read
and i think it can be read i think it is
read child with a disability shall
include a person between the ages of 18
and 21 inclusive who was identified as a
child with a disability but did not have
an individualized education program so
was identified but did not have an iep
in his or her last educational
institution
my understanding is that is that
children who may have had may have been
identified with a disability and had an
iep but the parents can later withdraw
from from that from that iep
and um
uh and and
you know and then you're you know if you
were to re-engage you'd have to start
from square one
um i i
i
i don't know if
if lines 13-17 are intended to um
uh to read that way but um
um and and largely that meaning is taken
from existing language
uh but uh but of course now is being
extended until the uh the student's 22nd
birthday so um i don't know if that's
something that um
that
this committee may want to um look at
further discussion on this bill
yes representatives
i just wanted to cover the grammar point
the earlier one 3 and 21 comma inclusive
comma is because you're referring to the
3 and the 21
and 18 and 21 inclusive no comma you're
further discussion representative
cordelli do you have thank you
just that um
as uh
representative luno was um discussing um
that uh last part of the amendment um is
what is in current statute now so
but i'm wondering what the
what the intent of that meaning is and
and
while you're looking that up
i like to look in the
page two of the commission
amendment
uh at item d
if the medicaid to schools program
eligibility extends to students
beyond age 21 that would that mean also
would you ask that question again i'm
just looking at numbers age 21 would be
22.
yes
so it would be inclusive so medicaid
would continue for that particular
student
i'm looking at item d on that page
yeah
but
the question is if yeah yeah it's an if
it's uh i mean it's a point of study but
it does not imply an answer yeah it's a
question
do we know that if medicaid would extend
based upon the way we're writing in the
oh
rick the the woman that testified
who wasn't on the hearing when we asked
specifically about medicaid
on 21 to 22 she said if you change the
law
then it would apply through 22. if we
didn't it wouldn't
that's my recollection yeah
yeah the the lady who was from the
background yeah yeah that was
represent nelson
thank you on page 2
line 10 i'm just wondering if there's a
problem here i doubt it but and it says
a year in which the student reaches 21
beyond the student's 21st year of age
could that go to 23 24 if it just says
i mean could that be beyond the could
the person be 25 and still get it i'm
it's another question it's just things
to look at as a right mission
yeah i mean i read it as the year beyond
21 in the school year during which the
student turns 21
but
again i think that's
the purpose of yeah that's the that's
the purpose of putting all of these
questions together and and being able to
come up with answers
before we attempt to write
statute that
doesn't fit the
so so if this committee um passes it and
it's passed on the floor of the house
it's um uh going it's an early bill so
it would likely be going to finance
um would
would
would it be possible i guess to um to
have a more detailed um fiscal note um
for for finance
that considers
not just the um the cost of the local
school district
and the cost of the state in terms of
adequacy grants
and
and special education grant but also the
costs that may be incurred through the
efa program and um and any other costs
that that might be relevant because i
don't think those are
are really um articulated
in the um in the note and um
and i think
it would be um
helpful for um for finance when looking
at the fiscal impact of this
potential policy change
uh to have a more comprehensive
fn
uh just in relation to one of the points
there um after
the discussion yesterday um i conferred
with attorney
fenton and we agreed that
efa students would not be covered under
this efa students with disabilities
as
in lines three and four or except four
and five it says
identified
by a school district so they would only
be covered if they were using the efa to
attend an out of um
out of district public school so so
follow up on on on that mr chair so so
let's just say for the for the point of
argument that that that a student was
identified by a school district as a
child with a disability at age three
and um
uh and attended that school district and
had an iep for a period of time
and then withdrew from that school
district to open an efa
and um
um and then um uh achieve you know
reach the age of 18
and um
and
decided to homeschool
uh at 18
and then read lines 13 to 17 of the
cordelia amendment which is largely an
existing law
where a child with a disability shall
include a person between the ages of 18
and 21 inclusive
who was a um i'm sorry
who was identified as a child with a
disability
back at age three but did not have an
iep at his or her last educational
institution
i i'm just you know i i think
and you know this is the this i think is
a situation where where where we where
the state can get in trouble when we try
to rush through um
policy changes
and i you know you've you've you've
obviously heard me and many of us lodge
many you know complaints about how the
efa program was rushed through the
process
so we do have policy that has been
rushed through the process and now this
um
somewhat being being rushed through and
how this reads and and i agree i mean
i'm glad um
attorney fenton
was able to to you know conclusively
say that that this doesn't apply but but
um you know and with all due respect
it's not attorneys attorney fentany's
call it's a court's call
and uh unless the legislative process
makes it clear what the legislative
intent is
um on that which uh which of course we
can help do when we write our committee
reports and and um and and making floor
remarks i don't know if these remarks
actually
you know get to legislative intent uh or
if attorney fenton's um um remarks could
somehow be incorporated into a fiscal
note uh which would uh which would
certainly indicate which would probably
indicate um legislative intent but those
those are that that's the concern i have
with this type of thing and all the more
reason why i think we really need to
is this really a uh
the issue you're looking at here you
using the you know the past tense that
was
rather than has or is
um
but that that's that's that's you know
more of a technical correction it's a
policy decision yes but it i don't think
it takes a a commission to make that
change
i understand what you're trying to say
though that because of the
how fast we've moved everything
this year and and the same thing's
occurring over there i was just talking
to jeff over in ols uh
prior to coming here he said just in the
last day and a half he's received 80
amendment requests
and and the day before that he had 113
and and so there's it's just
they're overloaded as well yeah so so
rick i guess what i'm what i'm saying is
is
um
there
we've we've already sent
um
uh
make sure you get the number right 13 15
15 13. we've already sent 1513
over to the senate um with it
not in its original form but in its
amended form um
the the the senate can still do what
they want with that
um
uh and and ultimately i think some of
these things are going to go to a
committee a conference
and um and you know i think
you know i think more more more
important is that is that we have a uh a
study
um
attached to uh
to 394 in its current form um
uh
then it is bringing 394 back to 1513's
original
uh form and uh and it may end up
there and i think there's enough sort of
policy out there
with this with the senate having 1513
and they can they can put it back into
its original form
uh
and then it can be ironed out i guess in
a in a conference report but but that
would at least give give the um
give a little a little bit more time to
uh to really understand what the um
you know what new hampshire's
compliance
issue is
represent cordelia
uh yes i i would um i guess disagree
slightly in that i i think that um it is
imperative that we uh
include the um 1513 original language
in this
and get this passed
when i left the senate
education
yesterday
when they ended their
exec session um they were held off on
um they had one amendment planning which
i'm not sure was but they were awaiting
an amendment by senator khan
as well and i'm not sure if they're
going to take that up today or or next
week um but i think it's imperative that
um we at least move forward with the um
original 1513 language
do you know this is the amendment i i do
not know what they were planning or what
senator khan was planning to say down
it's close to what i was given the other
day
and when i spoke i don't think they've
taken up that other amendment yet
no
that 1513 is still very much in their
possession i believe that they're acting
the commission study for me
is not a bad idea but i think it's too
much i think there's some stuff in there
that i think is needs a a different way
of addressing
the issue of catastrophic aid i think is
huge
and
i think it gets away from this issue of
22. yes represent woodcock thank you
just a question i'm not sure if
um
representative rosenberg from the
disability
has the answer or we do i just want to
muddy up the waters representative
nelson made me think of that
on section e uh bill will you talk about
how far the age could go
um i was wondering
i was trying to recall that at one point
when a student became 22
i thought they transitioned to the
rehabilitative services program
no
from high school
no i don't know if he will let you come
on up and and uh
um
yes voila
i'm karen rosenberg with the disability
rights center and i'd be happy to do my
best to answer your questions i don't
want to mind any further but uh nelson
brought up and then my brain went back
to olden days i thought at the end of 21
when the youngster turned 22 in school
that he was transitioned to
rehabilitative services well no not
necessarily so there are some students
who may be eligible who may be receiving
special education because they have
developmental disabilities or acquired
brain injuries and they
might be eligible for services through
our area agencies but that's only a
small sector of the students who are
eligible for special education you might
have other students who don't who aren't
able to graduate in high school in four
years for other reasons you know perhaps
they had emotional disabilities that
required them to be out of school for a
long time for example and we don't have
a sim a system like that that will
provide really robust services for them
so you have to kind of think about the
full range
of students
it's probably more often than not you
would have students with developmental
disabilities who aren't graduating on
time but not
not all of the time okay they answered
my question thank you very much
that may be the case but in fact
we're not providing any adequacy dollars
for those students that's coming from a
different source right so for the
students who are
getting receiving services through the
area agency system those are for
services that are not education services
that would be the responsibility of the
school district so they might get
respite services um there's sort of a
dispute about when those services when
some of the services have to kick in but
from our perspective that would include
other kinds of services that aren't
educational in nature so for example if
a student can receive their free
appropriate public education in the
regular public school but they have and
do just fine and they but they need
services at home that that would be the
responsibility of the area agency if
they needed you know some
other kinds of services at home that
aren't necessary for them to succeed in
school
but like i said it's not every student
would be eligible for those services
yeah
any further questions thank you very
much yes representative
thought you were asking
for after i don't not really sure who to
answer
of so
my question is
if we pass the
amount the sue's amendment
to get more information
and we don't pass
the amendment that puts it the way the
federal
held off those lawsuits or are we then
going to get those lawsuits does anybody
are you asking me that or i'm asking
anybody and so if you know if
if we don't do anything it stays at 21
like we have right now in law
right but if we do this
all i'm saying is if we do the sue's
amendment
without you know that we're looking into
this it says we're looking into this
and we don't pass
yet
are we still going to be hit with they
said that there were two lawsuits
pending
is that showing that we're doing enough
towards that
to hold off those amendments or are we
going to be hit unless we
does anybody know
i mean i can tell you that there has
been
a lot of there there have been there's
been development
in thinking about these lawsuits so i
think there are there are law firms who
are
con you know compiling evidence and
considering this and um so i think the
state is at risk
um if it doesn't bring itself into
compliance and
that just the rhode island decision is
actually a it was a court of appeals the
first circuit which is the court of
appeals for new hampshire so it's
controlling law in the state you know is
there a hundred percent certain to
certainty that um if people plaintiffs
brought that lawsuit that they would win
there's never 100 uncertainty right but
i think that it would be a pretty
labor-intensive discovery intensive
lawsuit
well so you
are aware of some of those do you think
they would hold off
if we
appeared to be looking at how to do this
or would i i only i i don't think that i
have the i just wondered so beyond me
that's fine
yeah
my crystal ball like just i'd have
dropped it
represented boom
thank you mr chair i don't have any
questions now i'm just one there's only
one amendment on the floor one four
seven that's right and i think we should
finish that before we go on anything
else also has to time
we last year we passed this bill it got
lost somewhere in the senate so we've
had plenty of time working on this
so i think we need to pass this
amendment and then go on and if somebody
can bring up with another amendment
thank you okay that's exactly what we
need to do representative mullen could i
just ask one more muddying question and
that is the effectiveness date of
representative cordelli's amendment
it's 2023 correct
yes
are you done with me thank you very much
just a quick question um do how long has
the um the inclusive language been in um
federal law
and glenn had it up there just a little
a moment ago so i'm
or or maybe maybe becky wilson
knows
looking for how long the inclusive
language has existed in federal law
um so the last time idea was
reauthorized was in 2004
so it may have been there before 2004
but at least since 2004 the language has
been there the lawsuit that folks are
talking about the first circuit decision
was in 2018
interpreting what that meant and then
there was another lawsuit out of
connecticut it started in connecticut
went to the second circuit and that i
believe was 2021 when that was decided
does that help you
sure it it definitely does so the the um
the the federal language has been in
there
since at least 2004 and the um the the
first circuit court of appeals decision
was 2018 in the rhode island case so
again that's been out there for so it's
been out there
right and then connecticut with 2021 and
there's i went out of hawaii as well and
i don't recall what year that was
decided and
thank you
did the lawsuits generate that are
generated out in
rhode island
a result of rhode island department of
education messing with this and changing
it from 21 22 or 21 through the end of
the semester or
no i think it's just the opposite i
think what happened i think what started
this was i think maybe it was i think it
was hawaii that brought the first case
and when the state actually lowered the
eligibility age in that state and then
there was a lawsuit brought to challenge
that and to have the court and it went
to the ninth circuit court of appeals to
look at what um you know whether they
were allowed to take advantage of that
exemption from serving 21 inclusive or
not and then hawaii ended up losing
and
which established in hawaii anyway it
had 21 inclusive was what the law was
because of these three factors
operating an adult education program you
know exactly what we talked about here
what attorney bond was talking about
with you at the hearing
so and then following that lawsuits were
filed in these other states
maine for example just didn't they
basically just saw the first circuit
decision and then
changed it on their own
and i think a lot of other states
already had been serving kids
through their 21st year
thank you okay jennifer did that occur
when you were an attorney for the
okay
is
yeah
but it still doesn't solve the problem
of the kid being dropped mid-year
all this talk that we're doing now and
the problem that
that we had that we wanted to solve
ralph
yeah so we move it so they turn 22 in
the middle of the year so then when we
make it so next year we're working on
the build so 22 and then 23 and then 24.
no i mean we've got to be a cut off
somewhere and the cutoff is
when they meet hit
21 at the end of age 21
it's planning you know it's not just
you know so just like anything when i
hit
65 i'm on medicare you know i don't have
any choice so i mean it's the same thing
so
okay when
except we're talking about
young people
that are
needing services and
in school and suddenly not in school and
maybe not understanding why and
it's just
i know i know it's complex i just feel
bad that we can't solve the problem that
we were trying to solve
okay after all this talk we tried i know
i know
this this uh is going to keep going here
it's in the senate right now it's going
to go to several other committees so
those who really want to get on top of
this and keep working on it work at it
madam clerk would you please call the
information
[Music]
in this live
lapse that we have time we have could i
ask a question
that i've held off asking while we
talked about these very important
matters of the legalities and so forth
but how do we describe a 21 year old
person as a child
is that a legal fiction or i don't mean
to be disrespectful i just don't
understand how at some point that
termination terminology doesn't change
to person or student or something else
there ought to be something in there i
can envision as a person who once was an
aide to a male child
in secondary school
and that person would stand up and walk
around the wall room
pulled the shades on the things in the
school and the teacher did her best
to keep the class on target
but he was totally disruptive and i
can't imagine what would have happened
had he been
21. i could not have controlled it i can
answer the question i got a 51 year old
child
that is
it's very subjective term
okay okay
let's go on and call the roll on this
one
so we are voting on amendment number one
four seven one h
um to sb 394 fn
representative cordelli yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm
representative blakis yes
representative moffett yes
representative hobson
yes representative ford yes
represent
yes
representative nelson yes
representative luna
yes
representative cornell yes represent
tanner
yes
representative ellison
representative mullen yes
representative woodcock
representative porter yes
representative paul yes
sullivan
yes
and chairman ladd yes
okay so the amendment passed is 19 to
zero consent
wait remember when you're jumping ah we
got to vote on a bill
mr chairman
may i make a motion sure
i would like to move
ought to pass
okay who made that woodcock for me okay
okay
so we have a motion on the table with
the maker of the motion like to speak to
her motion
uh i think we have said much about the
topic mr chair and how about the second
i agree with some of the moments okay so
we're the same there
okay okay
so we are voting on amendment number 148
h
to house bill 394 fn
representative cordelli
no
represent boom
yes
no
representative ford
representative sodi
no
uh representative litchfield emma know
representative luna
yes
representative cornell yes
representative tanner yes
representative allison
represent mullen yes
rob sam woodcock
representative porter yes
rajen paul yes
representative sullivan yes
you guys are gonna kill me but yeah i
you got the outcome
okay
so is there going to be a minority
report
oh that's that's a week that's exactly
right peace we're both trying to rush it
yes
to a committee amendment
yeah we need to do that
yeah yeah yeah
sort of
if you hadn't had one area i would have
voted for it the part i think stan
germain i would have voted for take it
out
there were 12 yeses and six notes okay
what was the vote 12 to what
12 7. who who is that who's absent
this is a modern math issue
no but i think melissa
didn't vote in her order and then yeah
oh from jennifer yes sir um
when you have two amendments like this
and you're not changing they're both
on the same topic they will be combined
over there by them if we took that over
now we wouldn't get it back today thank
you just curious thank you yeah
okay if you could do that because i know
they want to get these things into the
calendar
to
uh approve the bill ought to pass as as
amended
so
just so cordelia are you
who wants to make glenn makes it all
second okay
uh yes i'd like to move uh ought to pass
with amendment on house 394 and those
would be both amendments 1471 and 1488.
we'll second that
okay does everybody understand the
motion that's in before us
mr chair yes will ols combine the two
into one amendment with one number
that's we've got to have that done
and jennifer's going to do it as soon as
we have this vote
jen's shaking your head said yes so you
know
good
yep
to amen to approve
everybody understand what we're voting
on here
okay um would you please call the roll
please yes you're voting on senate bill
394 with amendments 471
8 and 1488h
um representative cordelli
yes litchfield is a yes boom
lacus yes
moffett
yes
hobson yes
ford
yes representative sodie yes
representative luno yes
sam cornell yes
tanner yes
representative ellison yes
and mullen yes
represent woodcock
represent porter yes president paul yes
representative sullivan yes
chairman ladd yes
19-0
actually i think we'll try to try to put
on consent because yeah
there's no dollar sign there right
right and so we'll we'll do that yeah
german land
last night at eight for the combining
amendments last night when i was here in
hhs going in
at 8 30 we finished the third amendment
on the bill and that issue came up and
it's probably the only time that and the
chair and nobody else knew uh lucy
webber and i agreed on something that
ols will combine them yeah and fix them
so they've been doing that this year i
know well yeah i remember doing it in
the past too yeah yep that can be done
okay
that's done
all righty so one more
yeah we have one more bill today
and that's sp
okay which number do i want to do first
1381.
okay i'm going to hand the gavel over to
you
okay we'll uh open the exact session on
house excuse me senate bill 420
establishing an extraordinary need grant
for schools
and i'll call on chairman ladd for a
motion
yes i'd like to recommend for sb 420
otp
thank you is there a second to that
uh representative boehm seconds
would the maker of the motion like to
speak to that motion yes i'd like to
make a further motion to amend the bill
by
adding
represented bomb
yeah
okay representative no he was just real
shook about agreeing with lucy that's
all
okay um
1381 is uh an amendment two for uh 20.
uh as you know 420 also is a bill as
presented to us
that is much like the fiscal capacity
disparity eight that's basically what it
is
very similar to what we've had in law
previously
at various times in our history here and
the bill further goes on and adds in
part two
the accountability for these grants
and the accountability language is
exactly the same accountability that
came out of task force for 2018.
those are the changes
to uh that are incorporated within this
questions
comments
from the committee
representative luno
thank you very much mr chair so so the
way i understand
that that that essentially lines five
through um
are the the grant that's in 420 as it
comes over to us
and what's been added is
section
2.
which representative ladd talks about as
the accountability
section
that's correct correct so i'm getting
getting this right and um
and so what the what the what the
accountability part is doing in section
two
is basically saying
if you're a poor district
meaning you've got not a lot of property
value
and you've got
a lot of
poor families
then before we give you any more money
you're going to have to tell us exactly
how you're going to use use this money
so if you're from a wealthy district or
from a district that doesn't have a lot
of poor kids um you can um you can go
ahead and use your state grant however
you want go ahead and use your local
dollars however you want but if you're
poor poor you better you better show us
what you're what you're doing here and
and you know um represent vlad
two three years ago and we had a we had
a similar um conversation when it came
to accountability
and uh and i think it was really clear
at that time that
accountability really should apply to
everybody and not just apply to
districts that are poor
like like you know without a lot of
property value like like let's say you
know newport
and um and districts that have a lot of
poor people um in it and uh and you know
what i have to take a look if they fall
into that category
as well
um because there was a
fiscal note that came with
i'm just not thought i'm finding it
no no no
before i pick on somebody yeah so so yes
so newport newport's one of the
districts that would receive the grant
that that uh i i mean i just think
that's
there's just a lack of fairness um there
to to say that if you're if you're from
a poor district and you're a poor kid
then you better be showing me how you're
using the the extraordinary what's
called extraordinary need grant so
there's extraordinary need but before we
give you that grant
you got to show us exactly how you're
going to do it i you know
i i i think the bill was good as it came
from the senate i think it can be
improved but i don't think um
with all due respect 1381 um i don't
think that improves it i think some of
your other um
i think another one of your amendments
representative ladd did did actually
improve
um the bill may not have made it perfect
but uh but you know send it in the right
direction but it wasn't uh 1381 thank
you
further discussion yes
representative porter
thank you mr chair um
i just have a question because this
often comes up when
[Music]
the state
is generous with some new funds that go
back to towns and cities there's usually
a debate well is this going to go into
programs
and teachers or is it going to go back
to the taxpayers
and i'm wondering under this um
to help with the trophy tax burden so
under the provisions of this amendment
if a district
chose to take this money and use it to
reduce property taxes by returning it to
the taxpayers would they then not get
this money uh um
is
funds which comes down through your
adequacy funding formula
i would hope they would not use it to
you know
do what you're saying that they use it
towards education but this is the same
way this would be used the same way that
our fiscal capacity disparity aid money
has been used in in the past
it's the same it would be used in the
same manner that came out of that
funding study back in 2008
it would it does require that you submit
a plan how you're going to try to
improve education
for what you are supposed to use this
money towards
and you will also be required to show
results and achievement results to the
department
annually
this is not the money that everybody
gets this is the money that only the
poor poor districts get
so no
you're not going to say everybody has to
submit this plan not everybody gets this
money so this is money over and above
what everybody else gets and
what we want them to do with it is
something that's going to help those
poor kids do better in education and so
that's the point of the accountability
it's don't just
spend it on whatever spend it on
something that's going to help those
kids we keep saying how are we going to
help the poor kids well just giving
money without
any
plan
is is
may help the kids may not we don't know
where it's going to go so the school has
to say yes we have a plan for helping
those very kids that this is money for i
think that's perfectly reasonable to try
uh yes
thank you very much mr chair no and i i
appreciate that i mean i think
um uh from the from the standpoint of
the um i mean remember there's two
factors involved here there's um there's
the taxpayer because it's got a
valuation component to it and there's
the uh the free and reduced price lunch
uh count which which which talks about
uh which is basically a proxy for uh for
families that uh
that that live in poverty and um
and and so so i think in all fairness to
representative porter's question given
that part of this is really tied to a
community's res wealth resource that
that reducing
using it to to reduce the local property
tax burden in some instances may be the
right thing to do i want to point out
also that in house bill 2 2.
there was a grant called the reductio
called the
swept reduction supplemental payment
and and it came in at 15.2 million
dollars so about a million dollars more
than the extraordinary need grant and
this went to and i've got the list here
but i got a squint to read it
i did make a few comments it went to
alton
it went to bartlett
it went to bridgewater
it went to
carroll it went to center harbor and i
could go on and on
i went to about 15 16 different
communities including wolfeboro
moultonborough tuftonboro rye newcastle
newington
and there was no accountability placed
on them in terms of how to use that
state grant of 15.2 million dollars um
so these wealthy communities no
accountability for using the grant so
not everybody got that grant just the
just these wealthy communities yet for
these poor communities oh no we need to
know exactly how they're going to use
this grant so that's what i'm talking
about fairness and i think overall
we should have a more robust
accountability clause when it comes to
our adequate education grant and um and
you know i
think that's something that i know
that's something that we're going to be
looking at in the 1680 study and which
was part of
a significant part of of house bill 1680
so i do take accountability seriously
but i don't take accountability as a as
a measure that we only foist upon um
communities that
that have extraordinary
uh needs
representative porter
thank you mr chair
um
it's
representative
lucas made some comments that
have me really concerned because the
assumption
seems to be
that a poor community
and a struggling school is not doing
everything it possibly can to help the
children learn
the teachers the administrators
the special ed teams and all those in
poor schools work just as hard
trying to make sure that all the
children learn
as those in the richer districts
the issues that they're trying to work
with
are far beyond what can be met
making these poor communities
justify
how they're using extra money to help
them
improve things
is insulting in my opinion
to those communities because you're
saying
well you must be doing everything wrong
because you're poor
and you're poor so i want you to prove
to me that you know how to do it the way
the rich communities do it you know how
to do it the way the other schools are
doing it obviously
you're poor so you must be doing
something wrong and i and i take real
exception to that and i am offended by
that
representative litchfield thank you
i was going to direct it to the chair
but he's handed over the gavel um i just
have to say that i've sat through
several executive sessions with this
committee now it's been very difficult
and it's extremely disappointing to hear
the manipulation of the words and how
they're twisted time and time again
we're saying okay to 14 million dollars
that we may not necessarily agree with
but we're saying that there needs to be
some accountability you know what maybe
it wasn't done that way in the past just
because it was done that way in the past
doesn't make it right but i can't help
but wonder did all of this nonsense with
the words go on years ago when there
weren't cameras because we're all on the
same team i know every single person in
this room cares about the kids i see it
you hit the desk you hit the desk with
your passion i know alicia cares i know
you care
can't we just stick to to what what
we're talking about at hand and not
not the volume with the words because i
thank you represent tanner
thank you
and um you know words matter i guess is
probably where i'll come down on that
one
that um
accountability is important and this
this particular
um
amendment outlines a lot of
accountability for these people
these schools that are
poor schools i guess we'll call them um
through
the the oversight of the department of
education and in identifying the program
and plans
then to
have an assessment either a statewide
assessment or some way of improving
instruction and learning identifying
pupils learning range
and um
that it's going to be
something that
you know measures student academic
achievement
and as representative porter said um and
i think part of the issue is that
a lot of us have worked in schools and
we've worked in schools and we've worked
have a lot of resources because of the
local property taxes and the property
base and some of them
that we've worked with
have not and we know what the difference
is
and it's not that people aren't trying
or that people don't have
plans or people aren't
trying to develop programs
to help kids
um
i think the
adding this particular accountability we
don't add this to charter schools
we don't add this to efa programs or
prenda or micro schools
we don't even have any kind of
accountability for home school and yet
you know because uh we have
the ability to give some extra money
to some of these schools to give this
grant
all of a sudden we've got more
accountability here than i've seen for a
lot of a lot of things that we've done
in the past
and i think it's um
as representative porter said and i know
teachers who teach in newport
teachers who teach at curesarge
and that's a
real rich district versus a real poor
district
that those teachers are trying as hard
as they can and that they teach
because they want the kids to succeed
and oftentimes at this level and one of
the reasons i'm here
is because when i'm teaching i thought
it was at this level
decisions were made
that put politics into into my classroom
that made it more difficult for me to
teach
and didn't affect the student
achievement
so um
yeah i think i think this accountability
is is too binding
and on some level insulting to um
to some of these schools that are going
to get it and i think it also could be
a way to say well we've we give them
money and nothing changes you know
that's that's another thing i've heard
is that you can't just throw money
towards education and
and uh make a difference and
it makes a difference i don't care what
you say
the schools that have the resources
have better student achievement than
schools that don't have the resources
and until we address the school funding
issue
on the basis of school performance
rather than on property tax base
you know nothing's really going to be
changed a whole lot
thank you
representative hopson
thank you mr chair and uh thank you for
taking my question
you know i i have a question about what
is
uh school success
because i i can't figure out if we're
measuring school success by the amount
of money that you spend on a student or
what their grades are because
my town doesn't qualify for any of this
aid but yet my elementary school went
from number 58 to number 122.
so could someone explain that to me
maybe you mr chair
mr chair
just um and on what basis was that
drop in from one thing to the other what
was it that was the ranking the state
ranking of the ranking based on what
on the doe what i i don't know based on
what how does the how does the doe rank
schools on testing
and growth
um
further discussion
yeah uh representative woodcock thank
you so i'm sorry
president uh
well yes this is edification not a it's
not a point of uh
just a point of information
the um
yeah thank you just the point of
information if you can so the this grant
is going to change
the i understand all right change the
formula so it becomes an annual
the increase of the annual
it's not a one-time funding
that's just a question
i'm trying to find a loophole trying to
answer it
i think that's a i think that's correct
this is a grant it's not a continuous
it's there for fy23 and fy24 if you look
at the fiscal note you'll see it drops
from 14 to 9 million dollars right um
it's uh based upon uh demographics
population
uh it's uh something that we've had
there's been a fiscal capacity disparity
a type
grant awarded
for as long as i can recall being in
this house
we've had something there similar to
this it's much like we have some federal
money that comes down to us through the
elementary secondary education act which
is designed
years ago used to call it title two
money and the money which we used for
remediation in schools which we're
acquired to and it went to schools
normally in my districts or where i was
that were those districts there's a
direct correlation between achievement
and the level of
economics within your community
and in the communities which are
receiving this there's a high incidence
of needs for achievement especially in
the
sub-components so groups within
which we're not seeing that going on now
in order for us in this state to really
show growth and achievement the way we
do we do need to have some methodology
in ascertaining we do that sort of
through the statewide assessment but
this also allows through this language
right here that you may do it through
your local assessment to ascertain
whether this is being used or whether
you're accomplishing what you need to
accomplish much like the feds ask us on
elementary secondary education act when
we receive those funds for remediation
okay thank you i was just asking because
a look at line 30 we're talking about
it's going to align itself with the
annual funding and not just a one-time
grant
that's why i was questioning that thank
you yeah um
maybe representative vlad
recalls i think uh several terms ago
um i think you were involved in a in
legislation that tried to um put some
accountability to the
special needs differentiated aid to see
where that money was going and what
happened with that
um is that am i correct i can't remember
the number of the bill but it had to do
with uh differentiated that component of
where we have if you are a third grader
and you're eligible
because of your level of achievement and
your statewide assessment reflects that
you're not proficient but not receiving
any other component in differentiated
free and reduced
those areas english language learner
then you qualified we tried to establish
some kind of a system for
uh
trying to identify whether those dollars
they're a small significant amount of
money it was somewhere around 600 bucks
at that time per per pupil
and we were trying to ascertain is this
really doing anything
and the only way of doing it was to
track that same cohort of students but
it was just a one-time contribution of
money and as you couldn't do that you
couldn't track the cohort as they went
up through to see if this was making a
difference or not
we don't have any real good methodology
for us
ascertaining whether in fact we are
seeing
achievement and especially growth uh
other than our statewide assessment and
you know i know that i am the cro i know
that i'm not really in infatuate
infatuated with the that methodology for
determining growth uh there's other ways
of doing that
um but that's not part of this
discussion
thank you very much mr chair so um
so just for um uh
just for
you know potentially technical support
on on the comment i'm i'm going to make
um we do have mark manginello here from
the from the department who i think
created the fiscal note i'm sure
on um on this bill but also has
extensive um background in
and rick and i work very closely with
mark and mickey on house bill 709
back in 2019 and so so i think he
understands very much what what goes
into the um the not only the the
educational uh the adequate education
grant which this is not actually part of
it's in the same section but it's not an
adequate education grant um and um and
also in the greater cons in the greater
context of what a uh what a district
spends
to to educate
their students and while i'm while i'm
here not trying to make people feel too
bad
i'm going to stop picking on manchester
and start picking on hillsboro a little
bit i'm glad marjorie's back and back in
the room
because i think this is going to help
also you know address what we're trying
to accomplish here again i do support
420 as it came over uh from the senate
and i understand this committee looks
very
provides substantial weight on what we
receive from the uh from the senate i'm
being a little facetious there
but
but what what 420 does for um for
hillsboro
is in the first year gives hillsborough
a little over 159 thousand dollars in
the second year a little over 120 uh 5
and um and
and so put that in the context of a
couple things uh first of all what
hillsborough's total school budget is
for approximately the thousand kids or
1100 kids that hillsborough does i don't
really know but i'm guessing it's 20 21
million dollars 22 million dollars
somewhere in that in that ballpark so
this is 159
and and also
at that at that spending level
at hillsborough hillsborough's average
student is is achieving at about the
15th percentile 20th percentile
statewide so so 50th percentile is
obviously state average so they're well
below state i'm not trying to make you
feel bad uh marjorie because your
teachers and the families are trying as
hard as they can um to um uh to to
provide a strong education for their
kids in fact hillsboro and hopkinton
used to be
rivals
on um on the um playing field and now
we're allies on the in many sports
and and have a terrific um um
association together but um but mr chair
actually uh representative lad i'm
really trying to figure out how much you
expect
159 thousand dollars
on top of hillsborough's 22 million
dollar budget to move that needle from
from current achievement at the 15th
percentile to
to anything else
so and um
since 1970
we have quadrupled and that's factoring
in
uh
the value of
the money
quadrupled the amount of money that we
have spent on
education and yet our outcomes are
straight they're aligned
and if you look at a map if you look at
a graph of
the amount of money each
state pays per pupil
versus
the outcomes it's like somebody threw a
piece of sand on a piece of paper there
is no correlation whatsoever between the
money spent
and the outcome and as long as we keep
looking at just spend more money spend
more money and don't look at
what are the underlying issues
why
are we still with all the money we've
spent
in the last 50 years
why have our outcomes not improved
it's clearly not money it's something
else and as long as we keep looking at
money we're never going to find what
that something else is
yes
we may be near the top in the
federal
you know rankings
but our students still are not that
proficient
and many of our students like you said
but if money if as long as we keep say
well let's give this money and just give
this money
that we're not going to pull them up
we need to figure out what the problem
is and solve the problem not just do the
money and so perhaps
with this little bit of accountability
that says what was your plan and how did
you do we might find
that one school does come up with
something that you know what this works
and then we can spread that across all
the schools but as long as we just give
money and don't ask what are you doing
with it and did it help how are we going
would would you like to start and then
represent tanner thank you very much mr
chair so so um
so
you know
the adage is money does not buy
happiness i get that and and we see that
all the time money does not necessarily
always buy results it depends on how
it's spent the department of education
has a tremendous amount of information
on how districts spend their money and
and i'm sure mark would be able to uh to
talk about that if if there was a
question that came up on that what the
school funding commission uh learned is
that there is a very strong correlation
between student outcomes and um and
poverty and student outcomes and lack of
resources and and so so
the better resourced districts do have
much stronger student outcomes than the
less resource districts and then i'd go
further on to say when you took a look
took a take a look at um at the um you
know course the programs the study um at
uh at a lot of um uh you know at a at a
s at a school like saint paul's or
phillips exeter obviously you know those
schools have have straight tuition that
is probably three times the average of
what we're uh what we're spending here
uh on our on on an average pub public
school
in new hampshire so so i guess what i'm
what i'm saying is no there's we have a
lot of data on what schools how schools
are spending money what their outcomes
are and um and that can certainly be uh
be correlated with um uh with with with
the
number of eligible free and reduced
price lunch kids which which sort of
tracks poverty in an area or val or um
assessed valuation uh per pupil which is
also a number that uh
that we have so i would certainly
recommend you know people taking a look
at the um the commission report which uh
which unpacked a lot of that uh
information and i think dispels a lot of
the um the sort of the wisdom that the
conventional wisdom that that people may
may bring bring to bear saying oh no you
spend more money on schools and it
doesn't um uh go anywhere because at the
end of the day
what's uh what's really important and
none of these bills that we've looked at
today
certainly 420 doesn't
it's it does some good things but it
doesn't separate out the two the two
functions of costing and education and
then funding in education costing what
an adequate education is is different
than fund then making sure a district
has access to the resources they need to
uh to pay for it and
and the the cost of an adequate
education the way it's defined in
current law the way that 420
essentially continues it is a
one-size-fits-all
proposition and the fact we don't have
one-size-fits-all communities in
new hampshire so um so what 420 does in
the very positive side is recognize that
different communities have different um
resources available to them through
their assessed valuation and different
communities have different cost factors
associated with inadequate education as
as determined by the um the free and
reduced price lunch uh piece of of 420.
it still blends them together but um but
uh it it it does i think follow some of
the some of the tenants that the school
funding commission found and that's the
reason i support and and i'm i'm quite
certain the reason why uh why senator
waters senator khan when they were here
both
both indicated their support um
bipartisan support for senator
hennessey's um
bill here i didn't hear any of them air
support for uh for stringent
accountability measures um
um
but um but anyway the the um
you know the the
school funding needs to be some school
costing and funding need uh need to be
looked at i think very closely uh here
and um and you know 420 is a
a starting point that can at least be
put in place to help
fy i think 23 is part of this yep um
july 1st 2022 is the effective date so
um to help uh to help out in the next
couple of years thank you
very much thank you um i'm looking at
the estimated uh
summary of adequacy aid for fy23 for our
state
and i'm looking at the amount of money
which we're allocating towards fnr
which is 82.4 million dollars
what we are doing with this type of uh
fiscal capacity disparity aid we're also
and that's based upon
that is based upon your your poverty
level the the the uh
money that i'm talking about that 82.4
million
i'm also looking at this equalized
property valuation per pupil which is
also based upon
level of poverty within communities
which is basically a grant which
supplements what we're providing for
and allows districts that are poor
districts to
try to uh
better their in achievement and in an
improvement amongst the kids
so
i i don't see any reason why we would be
objecting to this and even with that
accountability built in which we need to
have
because we we know there's a lot of
reasons why children
learn and they grow and it's not just
dollars which do it in fact that's one
of the primary reasons why i voted
against the commission report
that there's a lot of other issues
aspiration of the community education
levels within the community
leadership in the school is extremely
important the dedication of individual
teachers you have some teachers which
are superb not some a lot
but you have some that punch in and
punch out and that's that's it and
there's not a lot of a whole lot of
innovativeness i've seen it it's a
minority but it's it's not the majority
but you have it and those districts
which are supervised properly and and
have everybody playing on the same team
and the doors just don't close and it's
my bailiwick and i'll do what i want to
do you work cooperatively and
collaboratively together you're going to
see growth so there's a lot of issues
which come into play and growing yes you
need the dollars this all contributes
to great education
all best practices
may i
represent tanner
thank you um first of all i always
always uh
kind of bristle when i hear the you know
how much things have quadrupled in
cloths because
um i started teaching in 1969 70.
my first salary and i was at the top of
the of my entry level because i had a
master's degree at the time with seven
thousand dollars for the year
okay
um and i bought my first new car
that year which was three thousand
dollars
so
to say that things haven't gone up it's
gone up approximately
600 and
some
percentage plus okay the just an
inflation just just regular cost of
doing business
but on top of that um yeah money does
does make a difference um chairman ladd
um
i think everybody in newport not
everybody i can't speak for everybody
but i would say the community wants
their kids to succeed
um they want them to be educated and
they want to give them the best possible
opportunity
the people in the eight towns of
kearsarge want their kids to be
educated and have high aspirations as
well
the difference is
that a teacher
over newport at the top of the
teaching schedule
if there was an opening at kearsarge for
that or hanover for that or bow for that
teacher to change
probably would get like a twenty ten to
twenty thousand dollar
pay increase just in the change
if they were able to change
so what happens is newport has a
turnover of teachers every year
unbelievable
they've had an interim superintendent
for i don't know the last four or five
years
interim because they couldn't find
anybody to apply for that job at the
price that they had with the problems
that they have in the community that
they have to address
um and he's quitting because he can't
stand what's been happening the last
year with the school board and
the parents revolt and that sort of
thing
um
leadership um you know we went through
three or four superintendents while i
was teaching
went through maybe three or four
principles
newport has a new principal and a new
superintendent about every three or four
years
they have beginning teachers over there
that stay for maybe one or two years
they decide they want to stay in
teaching they get a job someplace else
and continuity um
the and it's based on money i mean
that's why people are moving that's why
people are changing there are some
teachers at at newport that have stayed
there for 40 years
and
but there are few
and they're very dedicated because
they're part of that community
but you know until we solve this problem
of the inequality
of
funding or financing however we want to
put it i'm not as into it as as
representative luna is but
from a basic level until we solve that
problem
you know the state tests are not going
to tell you the difference
and you're not going to get the
achievement um scores
uh because they're just not they're not
it's just not going to happen
and i think that's the root cause of of
a lot of things
and i don't think destroying public
um i
i just commented i don't think anyone is
talking about destroying the public
education
i see it
every day
at the risk of
being
yelled at again
i want to say that
me saying that we have brought up
hillsborough as an example
during my 15 20 years teaching in that
district we were part of every school
improvement program that was available
to us through the whole time everything
all the way back
to
1980s all the way up until 2002 the best
schools leadership program the regional
lab we were at target school we were
involved in a
an organization between
new england college and antioch college
and hillsborough to make things better
improve the climate improve the attitude
of the children make them want to do
more how can we do this better how can
we teach them better how can we reach
the community better how can we get
parents involved more how can we um make
make summer education available for kids
who need it how can we do all these
things we did everything possible that
our budget could afford
and as representative
tanner
expressed we we used to joke because we
would say we had the superintendent of
the week
we had high teacher turnover low teacher
pay
so yes the money does
matter
and the assumption that
there are that people are not trying
hard to make things better in a poor
school district
is
insulting to me
because i've lived it so please i know
it's difficult for you maybe to
understand there are metrics we can use
to determine if a school is doing well
and look at the graduates what happens
after they graduate where do they go
my kids went to the hillsborough schools
i told you about my kids
they certainly aren't failing because we
were poor we had low test scores
and they're on all of their um
compatriots all of their peers are doing
well so those are ways that we should
look not necessarily
thank you
representatives
i just wanted to clarify that i never
said anything about teachers not working
hard
so i don't i i don't appreciate that
being brought up
i was talking about plans
for different ways of doing things which
you've been working on
which has nothing to do with how hard
teachers are working and so no i have
not said that i've not said anything
against teachers i appreciate teachers
representative thank you speaking with
you
see no further comments um
is ready um
we're going to have a roll call vote on
mr chair could i ask a question
yes
so
when we looked at these um amendments
yesterday there were three of them
uh are are we
is there a plan for considering the
other two as well as this one or uh the
floor will be open to further amendment
yes okay thank you
clerk
what's the best way that you don't get
confused
what she's concerned about see he's
acting as because i'm making money
that hint is what got me into trouble
because
if it's unanimous and i go down the row
1 to 19 it's simple right but when we
start jockeying back and forth and
you're doing one and two
that's what's not
i'm old and it worked okay
and tell us to slow down if if we're
going too fast
yeah i was just going to say a clerk's
hint is rather than using checks
write a number down like one two that's
whatever works for the clerk works for
us
all right
um
so representative vlad yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm
yes
representative lakis
yes representative moffett
yes representative hobson
yes representative ford
yes
representative saudi yes
representative nelson yes
representative blue now
no
representative cornell no
representative tanner no
representative ellison no
representative mullen no
rep sam woodcock
representative porter no
representative hall no representative
sullivan no
and um representative chair cordelli
yes okay
uh does um yes does representative vlad
have further uh
amendment yes uh i would like to move
amendment 1384
to
sb4204 420 and spot to pass
is there a second
represent representative boehm seconds
um would you like to comment on your
motion
yes i would uh this this amendment is
adding one more piece of the puzzle to
this bill that we've been just working
on
uh we have the uh hennessey bill in the
uh accountability section
and this adds in a section four which
deals with
the
opportunity for an adequate education
looking at our differentiated aid the
component of special education
and what this does it has it breaks
special education aid down into two
separate categories
a category a which allocates two
thousand thirty seven dollars eleven
cents to those special education iep
areas which are part of that category a
and then it also provides uh
3 367 dollars and eight cents for the
category
b
which
includes uh the other 10 categories of
ieps within it
weighted formulas for
students that have handicapping
condition are widely used throughout
this country
well over 30 states are now doing this
well over
uh we have had sort of like a hybrid
model right now dealing with the
category of cat aid and then we have
this category for all students so it's
not really a weighted formula but it is
a hybrid
um what we're looking at now is giving
specific weights a weight of 0.54 of the
of the uh amount of the base
adequacy
to the students in the first two or
three iep
in uh
identifying disabilities that come under
category a
and then within category b the other ten
are funded at a a different percentage
that percentage is roughly around a
point eight
four or thereabouts i'd have to look
of the uh base adequacy amount
let me turn to that page so i can give
okay the
category b is a point eight nine three
thousand three hundred sixty seven
dollars and eight cents that's eighty
nine percent of the base
added on to the you know the base when
they when they get their differentiated
data and base adequacy we have within
our education funding formula
several components which are
uh constitutional mandated areas that's
the cost of a and every every student
gets the same amount of money in the
state regardless of their
their community's wealth or poverty they
get the base cost and then they also in
then you add in the areas that they get
for a differentiated aid if they qualify
and of course to qualify under special
ed you have to have an iep
and it's based upon one of those
categories
weighted categories have been used for
many many years in these other districts
and i think it's only fair
that we do that
we know that it costs a great deal more
money to have a student receiving
orthopedic services or a child that has
traumatic brain injury
or multiple handicaps
or has an area that is one of those high
cost high need areas of special
education
now there are some kids in speech that
only get a few minutes per week maybe 30
minutes maybe more maybe less even
but there are also some that get
more than that
so yes it could be considered high needs
but when you boil it down to what is the
average cost of those categories it per
person it comes up much much more money
is needed for those in the upper levels
we have not been funding it at the
levels we should be ever since i arrived
here in the house and i looked at the
formula which came out of 2007 as a flat
per capita cost that we've been funding
in differentiated aid
all students who have an iep are treated
the same with the exception if you're a
cat aid then but the district has to
kick in a significant hunk of dollar
there that's something we need to look
at down the roadways here and i suggest
we look at it quickly it wouldn't be
this year but we we've tried to do that
and other years have tried to drop that
three and a half times to two and a half
times that comes up to a lot of money
and uh but it takes a lot of money to
educate students too and i concur and i
agree on that and this is one area where
i feel it's necessary that this this com
element within the adequacy formula be
changed and and we
change the policy so it's more
reflective of needs i'm not saying we're
getting there all the way but just to
change this one area one area the
category b from a 0.54 to a 0.89 we're
increasing it somewhere between 14 and
15 million dollars
if you add on the total costs of the
extraordinary needs grant program and
this you're going to come up a little
shallow up 30 30 million dollars would
be added into our fy 23 and fi 24
budgets or fy23 that's what i'll say
fy23 this amount for this this component
here will not change it's not a grant it
won't it's part of the mandated portion
of the constitution portion of our of
our formula it will continue as long as
you have the students that qualify for
the iep if the same students are there
you will continue to get that amount of
money uh
with the condition that you know it's
changed every biennium by the cola
uh cost living so i guess that's quickly
i don't want to go too much longer here
on this we've discussed this previously
yeah thank you i'll be glad to take any
questions if it's necessary thank you uh
representative baum as second yeah
second yeah and just to
clarify things i hope
this this amendment 84 keeps
81 and adds
uh on page two from 15 down
so just so we should really be
discussing from blind 15 down on page
two just to
clarify things thank you
representative luno um thank you very
much mr chair and thank you very much
representative ladd for bringing this in
i was wondering if um if i've got a
question for mark if he wouldn't mind
taking it
the fy
adequacy spreadsheet
from the department
and
currently
the department has um
2037.11 cents and there is the
differentiated aid factor for special
education is that correct rick yes and
and
and the amendment that you're bringing
in
uh brings in
depending upon the category of the
student either an additional 2037
or an additional thirty three hundred
sixty seven dollars that's correct
yes it the the students which are in
category aid will continue to get that
amount which is currently projected
estimated for two fy twenty three the
okay
then the the students which qualify for
one of those ten categories in iep
identifying the iep
whether it be autism or hearing impaired
or some of the others have mentioned
okay they would get the 3 367
uh and eight cents uh per student
um so you can see there there is a uh a
difference there between a and b is
pretty significant difference at that a
and b and and there would still
exist a category that that
is um
not a and b is that right
or is a and b well if you're talking
about the cat aid but that's not part of
that no no i'm not talking about that
i'm talking about so
so for wait the weighted formula costs
then for differentiated so you
you said it's about 30 million
according to this sheet here for both
for i i said for both if you're adding
in the needs
the
extraordinary needs the fiscal capacity
portion 420. therefore
what was that 14
7 was it or
approximately something i can't i'd have
it was 14.6
yeah so i rounded out the 14 7 and then
if you added in the
cost of this particular program right
here
it's it's pretty close to the same
amount of money
so you're coming up to a total increase
in costs for you know that would have to
be fun another 30 approximately a little
shallow or 30 million dollars so did did
mark prepare this i i did that
um
mark do you have the ability to comment
on this
um
comment as far as is from the technical
perspective yeah so so
so i've got the i've got the the
department's fy23 adequacy spreadsheet
up here
and and if i just increase
the
make sure the two thousand thirty seven
dollars and eleven cents that's in there
now for special education and i just
bumped that up to 4 000
which doesn't even
you know
doesn't even come come close to
categories a or b
if i just bump that up to 4 000 it comes
to 119 million dollars
no i think you're not what am i you're
missing you're missing there are you
category a has 18 000 plus students in
it yeah
category b has 11 000 students in it
so that total universe
and and
for that that's the total universe of
special ed students i agree with that's
right so roughly 30 000 kids so so adam
at a minimum if everybody was just
category a
if everybody was just category a they'd
be getting the 2037
from the current adequacy formula and
from the amendment if everybody was just
category a so all i did was plug four
thousand dollars in to the adequacy
spreadsheet where it used to have 2037
so
2037 times two
and
and i get 119 million dollars not 30
million
i i i don't get where you are i'm not
sure what i'm missing here yeah
and so so that's why i'm i'm asking if
mark
if you take if you take 54
of the base what do you come up with two
thousand thirty seven dollars
right
you take eighty nine percent of the base
you come up with three thousand three
hundred sixty seven dollars and eight
cents
so
they're all going to get the base
adequacy it's just part of that part of
the side side of things but on the
special ed side that component
you're going to get either the 2000 or
the 3.3
thousand dollars depending upon which
category you're in
so am i correct in that the uh
uh students with a disability under
category a
get the 2037 as they currently do under
the 2023
um calculation correct but then
if those students
qualify instead for category b
instead of that two thousand dollars
they get the three thousand three sixty
seven that's right and it comes up to a
total of 75.5 million dollars
and then if you look at what we're
spending now at 60.6 million dollars so
the difference is roughly 14.8 million
or wherever you want to go on that
rounding off okay so it's not in a
you're not increasing special education
overall you're only increasing it for
the category b
student that's correct because it's a
weighted formula i'm using the weight
that we use right now
for those
kids that might be in like a resource
room who could have a learning
disability okay for those which have the
significant hard to deal with
i'd love to be able to fund them more
believe me
but you know i'm trying to be a realist
too at this time and dealing with our
budget
uh and they're waited out at that
particular amount that i have there
so it's overall that 14.87
what three
going on increase just just to i think
it's i think we've figured it out but
just to clap i've sort of eyeballed
representative lad's numbers here and i
haven't ran the spreadsheet myself but
just eyeballing it the the numbers
appear to work okay um so we'll if this
passes the house uh uh floor then we'll
have a fiscal note okay
but but yeah i think the easier way to
think about it is you're guaranteed that
2037 as constitutionally uh uh uh
required and then you get basically an
extra 1 330 dollars if you're in that uh
other category
right all right good thank you for your
explanation mark
uh any further questions for mark
before we let him uh get back to a more
comfortable seat
see none thank you very much um marjorie
okay
representative porter
thank you
i want to make sure i understand this
when we say an additional two thousand
three thirty seven eleven
for each pupil
please let me just finish
that language there
is
current
in the current law it says that
is that right that's
correct okay and then when we say
three thousand three hundred sixty seven
dollars and eight cents
is that three thousand three hundred
sixty seven dollars and eight cents over
and above the two thousand no or is it
instead of the two thousand that's
representative like this
i just wanted to say that this is
something that will reduce
property taxes because
the amount that we have to spend for
special ed is a fixed amount for each
student
and by the state paying more the
community doesn't have to pay as much
so that is the point of this
okay
it might not make property taxes go down
because it could enable school districts
to provide the special ed that they
should be providing so that we don't
have the problem that was brought up
this morning
um
represent representative hobson thank
you for mr chair um i i just want to say
that i think this is something that's
going to make
my constituents very happy they've been
looking for an increase
from the state so i think this will
may i add one last yes representative
just to give you some figures here so
you're aware where we are with our
population in terms of special education
students in the state
and why we need to do something like
this to
increase the weights
in 2008 we had 195
383 students
in the state
of that population
15.4 percent or 30
156 kids had ieps
now we have
262 kids
and of that population
18.2 percent
have ieps or 30
309.
so
we have more ieps
now than we had back in 2008 when we had
at least 10 percent more population in
the state
so it's it's a sign that
um and i don't believe we're over
identifying either
i don't believe that be the case we have
too many good professionals out there
which are speech pathologists or
physical therapists or
dealing with audiology dealing with all
these multiple handicaps we're talking
about i believe we have children and
after talking with my superintendent the
other day they're having a number of
kids coming in that are health impaired
now which is a category
and it's a significant category that
everybody's trying to get a good fix on
how do we help
and a lot of it's erupted as a result
the last couple years
and and without that socialization
without the the issue of being in
contact with the teacher there's a lot
of emotional problems are wrapped up in
that as well as well as physical health
issues
so
we have more ieps than we've had
ever
and we've got to start addressing this
heavy load which we have and we can't
rely upon
one of the issues which we have with our
whole costing formula and i hope
representative luno would also support
me on this that we have a per capita
formula it's not a program-based formula
it's based upon number of students in
your district it's not based upon the
programs that you have to deliver
and we need to start inching away from
that and getting into the business of
program budgeting
and i think this is a small step just
like we're landing on the moon a small
step and hopefully we can make it work
mr chair
yes uh represent tanner thank you i'm
just wondering if we have
the statistics of number one
from the census how many children are
actually in the state of new hampshire
and then
how many children
are out of that are in our public school
system which is the amount that you've
given us
and then also take into account
uh students between the time of 2008 and
now that have
gone to
homeschooling
that probably are uh
leave maybe a more of a concentration of
kids in public schools that do get
services rather than people that pull
their kids out and don't get services so
i'm just you know sometimes the
statistics aren't quite uh the same as
what
face value is i i really wonder if i
mean
you know you gave us those two
statistics where the percentage has gone
up but i'm wondering if there aren't
other factors that kind of uh go into
that rather than just more kids are
qualifying thanks
anything further
uh represent luna
thanks very much mr chair and um and you
know thanks for the earlier
clarification on the um the fiscal
impact uh on this
while you know i mentioned on monday
when uh when um representative ladd was
was talking about these three amendments
that that i felt it much more
appropriate for um for limited state
resources to be applied where they're
needed so
particularly the way sb 420 applies
limited state for resources to resource
limited and high
high cost you know high poverty uh
districts this uh you know
cross-the-board um increase to special
education i don't think is the best way
to use um uh state funds but given the
fiscal impact
on this and and and given the uh the
increase
in um in obviously special education
costs and as a percentage special
education students against the the total
student population i'm i'm certainly
going to be supporting this um this
amendment i don't like the the
part of the sandwich that's in the
middle but we've already voted on that
as part of it so so i'm really you know
weighing in on on section four here and
uh and i i think it's worth um uh worth
strong committee support
uh thank you representative i think
we're uh representative woodcock thank
you just waiting for you no no you're
very quiet i've been very quiet i know
thank you um
thanks cliff
um rick on the category a and b when the
state breaks it down for the for the
reimbursement to cities and towns
do they currently now at all identify i
mean i'm trying to think about the how
they're going to do this
the these categories are identified in
the cross sheet
but do they
when they are sending down a figure
that's based on
all 13 categories
how are they going to be able to to uh
um
determine this
they they they have on you can go on the
web and i i think i showed you one of
the sheets so it lists the number of
kids
yeah i saw that i mean darling that is
that's they have that's submitted by
every district they do have this
information there's been the issue
uh which i've been assured it can't be
resolved that you know if you have a
district of 10 kids yeah and it might be
you know you might run into that type
and we've talked about that 10 or less
kid districts uh that can be resolved
we're we're having to do that right now
if you have a district of 10 kids and
you're going to get differentiated aid
right of some kind it's going to be
there right now too it just won't say
which category you're in you just get
this two thousand some odd dollars
but i've been told that this can be done
okay um another way of doing this and i
i i'm not proposing it because i don't
like it is to find the in-between
percentage so that you continue to get
this money to the districts but it's not
based upon the policy it's not based
upon the weighted factor for those
categories that need this money
just one for auckland this would be
um this funding change
uh if process through the whole mill
would be the next biennium
the effective date of this is when it
would be allocated
to you know
but remember you're it's always a catch
up when you're behind right
okay thank you what the commission
report was trying to address okay thank
you uh chairman cordelia
representative hopson did you have a
last comment oh sorry yeah i just was
looking at um h uh sorry
sb 420 and it says that it'll take
effect 30
july 1st
2022. so does that mean
this will all be
ineffective
um
whenever you're ready
representative ladd yes
representative litchfield is
yes representative boehm
representative lacus yes
represent moffitt
yes
representative hobson
representative ford
yes representative soti yes from sam
nelson yes representable now yes
representative cornell yes represent
tanner
yes representative allison yes
represent mullin yes
representative woodcock
represent porter yes
representative hall yes
representative sullivan yes
and representative cordelli yes so the
representative vlad do you have a
further motion
is he bringing another one up
i'm not bringing another member is the
bill open to further amendment
okay i'm going to ask jennifer four for
a question here
we've
identified with two amendments
the latter amendment had the first
amendment incorporated into it
so
if in fact nothing else is done and i'm
not trying to say anything but i'm just
trying to get some process here
i think the way this amendment's drafted
is it would be compatible because it
replaces um only two parts in 198.40 f
in the original bill and those same two
parts that were in
um both amendments that we just passed
right
yeah
but i think we're trying to figure that
out i think this i think this amendment
would be compatible though in a in a
because it only replaces
yeah yeah
most i don't have it in front of me but
based on jen's advice
maybe based on jen's advice
um if there'd be a motion to reconsider
mr chairman in 1384. right
boom
and is there a second
i don't need to do that okay
board
mr chair
yes on the floor
if a bill is amended twice
the second amendment
is the one that
holds
oh i'm just wondering it doesn't work
that way in committees
but i i think what we've got here we
have one amendment that has exactly what
the other one has in it and it's going
to save some time over there with paul
smith
if we just you know get rid of the first
one
and then move forward with that second
one and take action which we have
um
okay so we have
a motion in a second on reconsideration
of amendment 1381
um
if we we could do it by just unanimously
you don't have to go through that
so we're just recalling 1381. we're just
well but we already voted for this one
which has all of this in it right
so so 1384 encompasses 1381
so we can get rid of 1381.
so is there a further motion on
uh amendment 1381 i'll move itl on uh
1381.
second by uh representative hopson i'm
gonna do a show at handsome yeah
everybody ready
the motion is itl on amendment 1381. all
i believe that also is unanimous madam
so
our status is
we currently have
uh
sb 420 amended by
amendment 1384
and we have a new amendment that's been
handed out 1477. 1477.
uh i think
luno and tanner yep and i'll speak
quickly to it if i might
yes so uh 1477 would um and i'm and i'm
looking at i'm looking at 1477 which
went around along with a a financial
analysis
on it um so i'm looking at 1477 and i'm
looking at 1384 which um which is now um
all of section one
of the of the bill
and um and so it would essentially
replace
in 1384
everything from lines 14 through
through
and um and so what it uh what it does
is is essentially doubles the um
the the extraordinary needs grant
for um uh for districts that have uh
less than um uh
well less than six million dollars in
equalized valuation per eligible free
and reduced price lunch
pupil in the admr
and um and
what uh
it does that by um by increasing the uh
the the highest amount uh grant from
650 dollars to 1250 dollars and then it
bleeds it down for every uh every dollar
of uh equalized valuation per special ed
pupil uh between a million dollars and
six million dollars by um
you can see it on line eight point zero
zero zero two five dollars
and um show you how that calculation was
made uh
it's it's pretty it's pretty simple um
at uh at a million dollars you get 12.50
per student at six million dollars you
get zero
and um and uh so 1250 divided by five
million gets you to that number and um
and what what does that mean what would
that mean for um uh for every district
and uh
and so the the financial and fiscal
analysis that uh that came through i
prepared it myself it was not uh
um
the lba
but but basically i took
the valuations from the department of
revenue administration's latest
valuation sheet i used valuation of all
property less utilities and railroads
which follows the language that
that was in
senator hennessey's
original bill it uses the
the free and reduced price lunch adm
from the department of ed's fy 23
spreadsheet
uh gets a um an
uh equalized valuation per pupil per
frpl pupil and then uh calculates based
on that the um the per pupil
grant the per frpl pupil grant that a
district would receive and that extends
that out in the final
column and you can see that that final
column totals to 28
million six hundred forty three thousand
dollars which is approximately double
what uh what is in the um uh what was in
uh
senate bill 420 as it came over to us
and uh and of course now we've we've
added another 14 million
on top of that with the uh with the
increase in um in category b
uh special education um uh
differentiated aid so so
what some what's what's important about
um about this is that uh is that it
applies to 28 million dollars so now
you're looking at two things the the
current bill is amended it's 28 million
dollars the amendment here is 28 million
dollars
um
and uh but it applies that uh it applies
that 28 million dollars to um to
property poor districts that have a lot
of poor families uh in it so it uh it it
in fact um
uh deploys state resources where they're
needed most and um and whether that
means that uh that
we we um
uh we want to do this on top of the
current amendment or uh or that this is
preferable over and above the um uh or
preferable over the um
the um uh the expanded
differentiated aid
i don't know but
given the conversation around here today
it seems like there's been strong
support to to get
state money and everybody knows revenues
have come in real strong uh and get them
out to uh reduce property taxes and uh
and and fund our schools and uh this
certainly puts uh puts 28 million six
hundred forty three thousand dollars
uh where it's needed most so i hope we
can have strong committee support on
this one thank you
uh representative tanner as the second
year um i just totally agree that we
need targeted aid to to these areas and
it's less than a parking garage so
thanks
uh
i i have a question about that yes i i
heard just then targeted aid
targeted to use for a specific
purpose
or does is it as we have the other
portions of our adequate formula right
now where it's stuffs
money sent down to the district
and the district uses as the district
feels they should
so can i i'll answer that yes rick thank
you mr chair so no i would i you know i
i would call this um as a good example
of of maybe what 20 years ago people
called targeted aid it was a very
conservative approach to school funding
i think it was opposed
largely um
by by
members from the party that i belonged
to back 20 years ago and
and
but i think it's it's abundantly clear
that
that that new hampshire is going to
continue to be a very revenue strapped
um uh state that uh that should deplan
it and it's already by far i mean it's
already the the applies the least amount
of state dollars per student of any
other state in the country by far
um and so um so you know i'm hoping that
new hampshire won't won't stay in that
position forever
this probably won't move the needle very
much in bringing us out of that uh that
position but but it's abundantly clear
at least to me that um that the state of
new hampshire is not going to be
um fully funding all of our our public
school costs for every city in town at
100 percent uh throughout the state so
um so where can you where can those
limited those precious state dollars uh
have the most um
have the most impact well it's by
targeting and that's what uh that's what
um some proposals going back 20 years uh
ago um looked to do and i said hey look
you know manchester's least funded
school in the state that students are
performing
um at the um you know
not at a at a at a very high level on um
on average
what can we do for manchester what can
we do for newport what can we do for
berlin what can we do for pittsfield and
um
and there's a bunch of bunch of
districts in that
in that boat and um
and that's what that's what this bill
does it basically adds 14 million
dollars to the to the current bill as
amended
that's 14 million dollars using the same
structure that uh sen that senator
hennessey
and um
and others
sent over here in uh in senate bill 420
and uh and that 14 million dollars is
less than the
[Music]
it's a million dollars less than the
targeted aid that that we're sending to
um um you know to alton and to wolfeboro
and to newcastle and to newington and to
portsmouth
um that was done in the state budget in
fact it's uh yeah it's a million dollars
less than that and if anybody wants to
see what the state budget did for those
districts i've got um i've got the
reports right here on that so i think if
we're if we're seeing it free and clear
to
to send 15 million dollars to
to support the absolute wealthiest
school districts um
in the state and the state spending 10
million dollars to bail out investors
who tried to get around securities laws
and uh and it's never been done anywhere
in the country yeah they were scammed
but they were taking their own risks
and um and so 10 million dollars there
then we can sure find 14 million dollars
to uh to help
our um our neediest districts by
expanding that extraordinary need grant
um and using the uh the state dollars
the best way possible thank you
representative
moffatt thank you miss chair
um i was taking notes listening intently
and part of the rationale representative
luno gave for moving ahead with this
measure was to quote unquote reduce
property taxes which
again i'm sure is on the record that's
being recorded so my ques my question i
guess is for representative luno
uh if part of the rationale for doing
this is as you just said is to reduce
property taxes how do you reconcile that
with the notion of targeted aid to help
schools
yeah thank you very much for the
question i think it is both um and and
i'm sure i didn't i hope i didn't just
say that that that this would this stop
this money would be used just to reduce
um uh property taxes because there are
some districts that um that have have
have definitely stepped up to the plate
probably well beyond what their fiscal
capacity is to uh to be able to fund a
um a strong education for their students
and there's other districts that are
trying so hard to uh to do that but
still can't um can't come close so those
districts may actually need to put
and it's a lot of them
may need to put put this money towards
program towards improving special
education towards improving other um
other programs that uh that student
takes in improving student outcomes um
and um um and
so i so i think it's i think it's it's a
lot of both on that uh representative
moffett and thank you for the question
thank you
uh representative hopson
thank you mr chair and if i could ask a
question of rep luno
so
um we've just
approved the bill as a as with the
amendment for 30 million dollars
and now this
uh your amendment seeks to put in
another
14 or 20 million 14.
so
when i go back to my towns which don't
qualify for any of this
that's 50 million dollars
the only benefit that i can tell them i
worked to get for them is potentially
a couple of thousand dollars for the
special education students
they're dealing with tripled electric
bills
doubled gas bills
we're all feeling
this
i
i just want to know what what am i
supposed to tell you yeah so so no i
think that's a great a great question um
you know i was really disappointed to
hear that that there was one senator
that uh that voted against um um senate
bill 420 because it didn't do anything
for um for their district and um and i'm
profoundly disappointed by that because
i think all of us have responsibilities
that go beyond our um uh just
funding the schools in our own districts
because the businesses in our districts
the higher kids from manchester so it's
important to me and hopkinton that that
kids in manchester get a strong
education um honestly the bill that we
just the amendment that we just passed
didn't do much for hopkinton and in fact
the the amendment that i'm showing you
right here does nothing for hopkinton
you know what i got a couple of people
in the trades over at my house today and
um and um you know what they might
actually if they were if they were
members of this legislature they might
be sitting on the other side of the room
and and i said look i'm introducing
amendments um and i've got a couple more
to talk about that that honestly don't
do that much for hopkinton but they do a
lot of good across the state and they
said that's good because that's what we
i i agree with you um i would like to
see all of our students
succeed i would like all of our towns to
succeed
as a state i feel pride
um
i just lost my thought i'm sorry sorry
well i mean
i'll i'll
i'll
go at a go out of thought um
you know
if that's the way you feel about this
i'm really wondering how people feel
about the 15.2 million that was um that
was
sent as a extraordinary
wealth grant to um to our wealthiest
communities um as part of the budget you
know so so i mean that's 15 million
dollars going to specific
communities didn't go to hopkinton uh
might have gone to kingston i don't know
um i'd have to look at the uh
i could look at the report but um but
you know that
i i think i think people across the
state recognize where there's need and
recognize the importance of applying
limited state resources where they're
needed not where they're not needed and
and so that's what that's what this
amendment um seeks to do
i had a follow-up i remembered what i
wanted to say uh it's about continuing
this you know now we have
money
in the trust fund it's it's when we
don't have money in the trust fund that
i'm that i'm concerned about spending
beyond our our needs so that's all i
wanted to say but thank you for your
comment
uh
see no further
i think uh i think the clerk is uh
all right we are voting on amendment
number 1477
to senate bill 420
representative ladd no
representative litchfield let's know
representative boehm
representative blakis no representative
moffett
no representative hobson
no representative ford
no representative saudi no
representative nelson no
president of luna
yes
representative cornell yes
representative tanner yes representative
allison yes representative mullin yes
represent woodcock yes president porter
yes representative paul yes
representative sullivan yes
and representative cordelli no
so this amendment fails to pass um
mr chair
do i hear something from somewhere yeah
uh
representative luna
thank you very much um i would like to
um
and somebody might want a second thought
representative luno and seconded by
mr chair
yeah before we begin discussion of this
while we're passing this out we'll uh
yes
okay folks uh we're gonna have to get
going here if anybody's out in the
hallway could you please let them know
the original bill no no no no
the amended the bill is amended
so this is going to have to work out the
laundry
well
house policy on both sides right
i think uh i think we're about ready to
uh reconvene
and right it was uh luno and tanner i
believe um
i'll call on representative luna if you
have be delighted to be delighted to
introduce this thank you very much um um
mr chair so um
so i'm now speaking to uh amendment 1478
um which um
uh let's see
would uh would would probably need to um
uh have some massaging if it were to be
adopted uh into a committee amendment
with uh with 1384
but uh but let's take it one step at a
time let me just talk to the amendment
and not the technical work that would
have to uh go in should it uh should it
be recommended but um what um
what uh what 1478 does is actually
replace the um
the
uh what i would call the the resources
free and reduced price lunch
uh extraordinary need grant
uh as presented to us in um in senate
bill 420 and replace it with a
with a fiscal capacity disparity grant
that that we've talked about uh in this
committee before
and um and was uh was part of
the
the the fy
uh
2021 uh budget and part of uh house bill
709 that that had passed this committee
back in 2019 and uh was nearly
unanimously you know passed on the um on
the floor of the house
and um and in fact it mirrors that um uh
that that policy
in in the in the fy 20 fy 21
state budget um almost right down to the
dollar so
so uh again uh 1478 pulls out the um the
the the grant design that was in senate
bill 420 is presented and replaces it
and it replaces it with a with a policy
that uh that is just based on a
municipal municipal municipality's
equalized valuation per pupil not per
pre-introduced price lunch pupil not per
special education pupil per pupil full
adm
and so for a municipality that has an
equalized valuation per pupil
of 500 000
or less uh they'll receive a an
additional grant of 2 000 per pupil in
the municipalities
admr the municipalities enrollment
that tapers off
between
500 000
and 1.1 million dollars and it tapers
again it's it's pretty easy uh to
calculate it's the two thousand dollars
uh chipped away
over over that um that one point six
million dollar range from five hundred
thousand dollars to 1.1 million dollars
and uh and it does that at uh at
um uh
point zero zero three three
uh dollars per
0.333 dollars for every dollar
difference in
uh in the equalized valuation per pupil
and um and that 1.1 million dollar
point
i've also sent around a spreadsheet
again i prepared this not mark not
not the legislative budget assistant
and um
and it shows that calculation it shows
the the total uh grant that would be
received by every municipality across
the state
i apologize i did not clean up
nor did i in the in the last one of the
divide by zero errors for unincorporated
places i just clearly um built them into
the um the list so that uh so that it
was easy to
to do the lookups with the with the
department of revenue information so
administration
valuation data and it comes to uh just a
little over 49 million dollars which i
think is right practically
at the
at the at the spot we were at in house
bill 709 and which ultimately became
part of um
house bill 2 the state budget in
fy 20 and 21. so um
so
uh and it's and it's not because i
didn't like the um
the the policy that was uh that was sent
over
um uh i but i wanted to to show this
committee what uh what a 50 million
dollar um uh uh fiscal capacity
disparity grant would uh would look like
what it would mean to um uh to various
communities
across the state and again i always urge
people to use discipline and before
going to um
to your own community um you know take a
look at uh you know take a look at
manchester and um and what it would mean
uh what it would mean to them take a
look at milford
and um
and
so that's that's really the explanation
of this and uh i'm i'm probably
not going to um
to uh to offer a third amendment so uh
so um but uh but i can tell you what the
third amendment uh would do is combine
back in
the um
the extraordinary need grant based on
resources and free and reduced price
lunch in addition to fiscal capacity
disparity and um uh and i believe uh
honestly i believe that would be the the
best um use of um of state funds in uh
in supporting school districts who
support all of our students needs
across the state so um
i'm i'm happy to take some questions i
hope you'd look at this favorably thank
you
thank you representative tanner did you
have anything to add
yes i do uh first of all i'd like to
say that i find uh representatives
luno's extraordinary
uh detailed
uh spreadsheets and and
really appreciate the fact that these
amendments are meant
to point out
how
aid of financial aid from the state
can and should go to the towns that they
really need it
and
what a difference it might make i mean
to look down and see claremont which is
not far from where i live although it's
not one of my eight towns
over three million dollars
and uh
you know i think it's
you know we keep harping on
until till education funding is solved
in the state of new hampshire
so that schools get adequate funding and
we're not at the bottom of the barrel in
state aid to education
um
you know i think i think i appreciate
these amendments and i appreciate the
discussion that it sparks so i want to
uh representative like lakers
i guess it goes back to and i've had
this problem with all of these
it goes back to the um equalized
valuation and
and
putting everything on that
um when what our evaluation in a town is
has a lot more to do with
the
desire the desirability versus the
amount the number of
homes available as opposed to how much
somebody can
a town can actually afford to pay
and i point again to my 200 at this
point almost 250 year old home that i
bought for 82 000 that is today valued
at
three hundred and eighty two thousand
dollars
and uh that didn't change my ability to
pay my taxes and we do pay twice the
taxes i mean for an average
an average home in hudson pays twice the
taxes of an average home in berlin
and
you know it it it drives our taxes up it
drives what we have to pay up but i
don't see how it drives our ability to
pay unless we sell that home
and as long as you're still in your home
you're not realizing any of that
increased valuation yet it comes out and
we're basing things on it and why are
why is property in my town so
expensive because there aren't enough
homes across the border from mass for
people to move to and so it's become a
popular place there are more people
wanting to move the move there it didn't
change what the people in my town are
making
yes you may represent tanner
thank you um property tax is a vision of
the early early settlement of of the
united states and how they chose to
to say who had the ability to pay if had
property
you had the ability to pay over the
years it's become a regressive tax it's
considered a very regressive tax because
it in fact you're right it doesn't give
an accurate in indication of a person's
ability to pay
and that's why
a more statewide tax
is is more considered more progressive
however new hampshire has decided to
stay with the regressive property tax
and use it for almost everything and
particularly education and that's why
it's a that's why
part of the reason we're having the
problems we're having
baum
thank you and i
represent on alicia's
in the south
southern part of the state
say a three hundred thousand dollar
house that same house up in berlin or
claremont it's probably a hundred fifty
thousand dollar house
so they're saying hey
this is
and so if their property tax is double
mined
they're paying the same amount of money
so that's the problem with property
taxes and in claremont in most of the
south
and in berlin too and most of the
southern part of the state your school
property taxes are probably 75 percent
of your total taxes and your town and
county is like 25 percent total in
claremont it's 50 percent is municipal
taxes and berlin is the same so it's not
the school tax problem in berlin or
clermont it's the municipal tax problem
in claremont and berlin thank you
representative lakers
and that's why we leave it up to the
towns to decide how much they're going
to pay for their things because if you
look how much does it cost for a teacher
to live
around our area how much does it cost
for a teacher to live around berlin so
yeah the cost of the education is going
to be different in each case and so you
can't i'm just saying this that's
there's
basing how much or deciding whether what
people have in etc
based on this is
it's it's an issue and
but you can't compare
different parts of the state anyways
because what it caught what it cost to
representative luna thank you very much
mr chair so um yeah i want to uh i want
to unpack that one a little bit a little
bit too
uh i want to start though um
because i think what what representative
leakes just mentioned something that
representative ladd mentioned earlier
today which is the aspirations of a
of a of a town for their schools and
maybe they don't have very strong
aspiration for their schools maybe they
think everybody should should receive a
very minimal education like was
proposed to us earlier
this year in house bill was it 1371
something like that
and
uh or maybe they want to provide hardly
any education that's up to the town
leave it up to them no
can't just leave it up to them our state
constitution says otherwise our state
constitution says the state is
responsible to make sure that every
student in the state has an opportunity
for an adequate education and the state
needs to come in and do its job to make
sure that every municipality has access
to the resources they need to provide an
adequate education an opportunity for an
adequate education for their students
we've also talked today about how
important an opportunity for an adequate
education or i should say an adequate
education
can be looked at through student
outcomes and um and why should throwing
125 000
to hillsborough expect that hillsborough
is going to somehow magically
uh go from 15th percentile to 50th
percentile do we really think
hillsborough's aspiration is for their
students to be achieving at the 15th
percentile i bet not i bet people in
hillsborough are working damn hard to uh
to to to find the money to put and fund
their schools and they're doing they're
doing the hardest they can but they need
a little bit more support from the state
so what would um what would this do for
hillsborough i haven't even looked um
and um
and
for hillsboro would go would bring in
uh put eight hundred fifty two thousand
dollars uh to hillsborough um
certainly a lot more than the hundred
fifty thousand dollars that um that that
hillsboro seeing in the um uh in the
other bill i mean in the um in the in
the original bill but um uh
is enough to move the needle
you know what
you start giving a district a million
dollars on on top of a you know
underfunded district yeah that's
starting to move the needle it's moving
the needle for claremont it would move
the needle for berlin it would move the
needle for for pittsfield and for
hillsborough um and a lot of districts
across the state so no it's not just
left up to the to the town to decide
whatever they want to do we have a
responsibility around this table we have
a responsibility in the legislature and
the governor's got a responsibility to
uh to make sure that um that that every
student has opportunity for an adequate
education it's the state's
responsibility to make sure that
districts have the access to the
resources they need to make sure that
happens i agree with you alicia that
that that the costs in every district uh
can be different you use the word costs
i was really careful in listening uh to
that but um
but but i think what you may have meant
to say was that was that the funding in
every in every do all right the costs in
every district meaning districts that
have more free and reduced price lunch
students it's going to cost a little
more districts that have more special
education students it's going to cost a
little bit more
districts that have a high
english language learning population
it's going to cost a little bit more and
that can be calculated out for every
district in the state to provide an
opportunity for an adequate education
and you'll clearly see that it costs
more to educate a thousand students in
manchester than a thousand students in
bedford uh based on that but bedford's
access to resources is much greater than
manchester's access to resources
and that's all these bills that's all
these amendments
try to uh try to bear out they look at
it different ways and i and i i really
do applaud senator hennessy
for
trying to
sandwich together in a in a in a in a
framework that only looks at funding and
not not looks at costing uh a solution
that tries to factor in both of uh both
of those things
and um and and um and so you know i i
just i'm i'm grateful that that this
committee today
can can at least put forward um senate
bill 420 and that um and that framework
i'm i'm you know i think
we've done a lot of talking i don't
think the accountability thing is well
placed at all
and um uh and i and i do think uh
special education certainly deserves uh
increased funding but the best use of
state dollars are where they're needed
most and that's what these amendments
i've been sitting here quietly all day
but uh i figure before we finish i'll
get my two cents in um i live in
grantham
and grantham is uh
got a really great school
and funds the school very well i go to
the school district meeting every year
and we
vote to pass a budget that's very
generous for the school we do a good job
i live one town north
of croydon
according has been in the news i won't
even get into that
i live two towns north of newport
newport struggles as representative
tanner was pointing out earlier they are
a school that bleeds teachers every year
because they don't they can't afford to
pay them
and um and we have chosen a uh
property tax to support our schools
it doesn't work very well but it's what
we've got right now
what this amendment will do
will try to help out oh and by the way
it does nothing for grantham um
and my friends in grantham are okay with
that
they get the fact that we are a lucky
town we've got a lot of um valuable
property
much more property value than newport's
got
and
my friends in grantham are willing to
see
newport and get money that we don't get
because we can see very easily that we'd
rather be sending our kids to school in
grantham
than in newport
um so i'm gonna support this uh this
amendment because it it does good things
for towns like newport even though it
does nothing for towns like grantham
thank you
for the representative vlad
you know i've been listening to this
conversation here and um
represent luna you and i have been
through this many many times this is you
know all the factors and the elements
that go into a formula like this
and we're this formula that you're
presenting today
is
really premised around equalized
valuation per pupil
on property valuation
now when i look at some of the
communities in this state
where folks are really struggling
they're in communities where that
equalized valuation per pupil is up at 8
million bucks
and i'm talking about lincoln and
woodstock
as an example
and there the people that are working in
those ski areas are
earning that minimal wage or those
restaurants or those retail shops
and
there is when i look at the achievement
scores of kids over there they're
they're not that great
and the growth it's not that great
um so
when we looked at this formula back in
2008 and 2009
we did not base totally on property
valuation it was also contingent upon
and
when we have a formula that's premised
around the singular element
there are going to be some inequal
unequal
inequities involved in here
and
although i like portions of this and i
understand my community would really
benefit
uh it's it's i don't know if we're there
yet
um in the formula that i see that for
example
uh aaron hennessey put forward senator
hennessey i looked at the town small
town of monroe
monroe is a small k through 6 district
tuitions their kids to st johnsbury
academy it all also has on the
connecticut river where there's a huge
huge dam that generates a lot of power
and a lot of bucks
under her plan they do receive money and
on this other one they receive zero
um
so i i'm trying to work work this out in
my mind what way do we go on this and
and um
although i see portions of this which
are wonderful for certain communities
there's other communities which have
these unusual
characteristics that we're not
addressing
how do we how do we help lincoln
how do we help woodstock where the
i'll just say carroll county
the meat as of a few years ago the
medium family income for the county was
the second lowest county
in the state
fifty thousand dollars but we have
four or five so-called donor towns in in
the county as well
representative luna thank you very much
mr chair um just uh just to be um
specific just looking at
lincoln woodstock cooperative school
district student outcomes their average
student
performs at somewhere around the 75th
percentile so that's that's
significantly above
state average
lincoln woodstock also
lincoln has
has some of the highest property
valuations some of the lowest price the
lowest one of the lower um uh property
tax rates in the state so do uh do a lot
of towns um uh in uh in carroll county
too particularly the ones along uh along
the lakes and um um and you know for the
people that uh for for folks who uh who
who live on a um uh live right on lake
winnipesaukee in a four five six million
dollar
home uh they're probably feeling lucky
that they're not having to pay the
property tax rate that people are paying
in hillsborough or newport or hopkinton
or claremont or berlin
because it would probably not make that
home a a four five six million dollar
home
um anymore um uh the the property tax
rates and it's not just that that that
the property tax rate one community is
twice that of another community in some
cases we're seeing almost a factor of 10
uh difference between say let's say
newcastle and um and um and claremont
and and so you know putting that in
perspective uh somebody that that buys a
um
a um
i don't even know if you can find a
three million dollar home in um in
newcastle but let's say a six million
dollar home in newcastle could be paying
um um you know
almost the same property taxes as uh as
somebody who lives in a um
you know an average house in claremont
same dollars in property taxes but a six
million dollar home and um and you know
they could have moved up from new york
city they could be a money manager in
manhattan come up on weekends um pretty
sure that the person who bought that six
million dollar home again it's access to
resources
has access to resources beyond what the
average homeowner in uh in claremont um
has so so just to say that somebody
should go from one community paying
paying you know uh a fraction of a
percent of their home value in property
taxes and then in another community
claremont i think it's nearly five
percent isn't it fifty dollars per
thousand yes
like close to that so five percent of
their home value in property taxes and
that's what the equalized valuation per
pupil formula straight formula goes to
uh goes to at least providing some state
support um for um uh for those
communities and it does so in a measured
way where it uh provides the greatest
support to the communities with the with
the least valuation and then tapers that
off as you approach to the average
um in
uh in new hampshire so um
a representative like
i'm just making sure i understand so
you're saying five percent is high and
out of line and they shouldn't have to
pay that i pay that
and we have a good school
and we pay
lower than the average
um
state expenditure per pupil in hudson
right
over
what's 80 i didn't say
no
so so um
so 5
is 50 per thousand
tax rate
right
yes
i'm waiting to find out where you're
going
what's that i'm not arguing with you oh
i thought i thought you were no i was
no my comment was if 5
you gave us forms a while ago that told
us what percentage each town paid and
how much money each town paid on an
average house and that was the things i
was going from the stuff you passed out
earlier
at another time
and
that's why i'm wondering you know a
bunch of us pay that much in our taxes
and um and i noticed on that form that
yes we we tend to pay on our average
house in our town compared to an average
house in berlin i don't remember what it
was in claremont we tend to pay twice as
much because our houses are valued at
more but we tend to make twice as much
so to me that's equitable
i mean i don't see that as a problem
and
we we pay we pay less but we spend less
per pupil in our town than the state
average
and we do very well and that's why i'm
saying i don't think either property
valuation or spending or whatever has a
you know that you can draw these
conclusions from that
um no i mean you can you can draw a lot
of conclusions from tax rates
and hudson pays uh in 2020 total tax
rate was 2137
you can't compare rates you have to pair
compare amounts
no you can compare rates
they're
you absolutely can compare rates
um
that's based on equalized valuations but
our evaluations are much higher so a
slower rate will give you the same
amount of money i understand that's why
i'm saying that's why i'm saying you
have to compare amounts because rates
are all totally dependent upon what your
valuation so somebody that lives in
in in twice the value home in in hudson
earning earning a higher um
income living on the massachusetts
border pays the same amount as somebody
living in a home worth half as much uh
working in claremont that's what you're
saying
i don't know about claremont i know we
paid twice as much as berlin
okay
um
anything further from and i don't have a
pretty committing
anything further from the committee
on the amendment
uh scene nothing
madam clerk
representative ladd no
representative litchfield does no
representative boehm
representative blakis no
represent moffett
no
representative hobson
represent
no
representative sodie nope
nelson
representative luno
yes
representative for now
representative tanner yes
representative allison
represent mullen yes
represent woodcock yeah
represent porter yes representative hall
yes
representative sullivan yes
and representative pordelli
no so the amendment fails ten days to um
nine years
okay let's all see what's up right i
think we're uh
back down to our last motion
um
representative vlad yes i'd like to make
a motion not to pass in 420 as amended
with
is there a second
representative baum i see his hand
uh any further discussion
no no i'll pass it amended pass
okay
representative ladd
yes
representative litchfield is yes
representative boehm representative
lakes
yes reza moffett
yes
represent hobson
yes represent ford
yes representative soti
yes
representative
nelson yes
representative luno yes
represent cornell yes
represent
oops
representative tanner yes
representative ellison yes
represent mullen yes
represent boydcock yes
represent porter yes
representative hall yes
representative sullivan yes
and representative cordelli yes
so the octopass is amended carries 19 to
zero
is consent okay with
bit of everybody on this one yeah
i think it ought to go on the road okay
okay
very good i i think uh mr chairman we
are complete for the day yeah uh we're
going to be starting next tuesday at 10
o'clock
yes
okay
um so this leaves these five bills which
we have to address
uh we'll be getting uh the
bills coming up on tuesday
you'll get a hold of those right off
here
two of them are coming up with
um i see if i can
see they're available
it'll be in the calendar i gave my sheet
what days are we meeting next week
uh not on tuesday
there will be one coming at us on
cooperative school board
on the following tuesday which will be
uh the
two bills coming up to have non-germain
amendments for
tuesday coming here do you have those
down i give my sheet to lindsay
okay yeah 353 353 and oh i'm sorry no no
no no no no
236 and 352
236 and 352 350
go ahead i believe we have the
amendments on both of those and we will
mail those out to the committee those
will be in the calendar also
um
see on on 352 the amendment's going to
and um the other one which is which
number 236
the amendment deals with um
modifying
the team statute on student loan
forgiveness
yes
we we had a teacher in the state that
had the same credential as the person in
the high school
but because they were teaching the same
subject
in the middle school
they didn't get any loan forgiveness
where the teacher was teaching in the
high school got loan forgiveness it's a
federal law they're looking at our state
other states where they have that by the
certification the requirements if they
were in the middle school
that individual in another state would
have gotten loan forgiveness but because
the the poor teacher in the middle
school didn't get any forgiveness same
exact
credential teaching the same thing
two kids which are prepared for it in
the middle school in the eighth grade
you know as we're trying to teach
competencies it's something that has to
be fixed
so it's nothing i don't think that's
really off the charts uh we're just
trying to assist uh an individual that
was
elsewhere in this state
that
i believe it's in
its statute it's in statute
basically a definition problem it's uh
it's going to have to modify uh rsa 189
colon 25
and the sentence what's in this
particular non-germain amendment reads
as such
provided however however that for the
purpose of eligibility for state or
federal teacher loan forgiveness
programs
teachers of grades 7 through 12 shall be
considered teachers of secondary school
let's see in our state k through eight
elementary
um and then uh
if so if you're an elementary teacher or
a middle school teacher you don't get
permeate
thank you very much have a good evening
drive safe lee
yeah uh we need to have the committee
today
time to go home